foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thanks
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh we missed it oh yeah oh my goodness
the wheels the wheels have come out that
could be the magic for some this is
familiar ground oh my goodness 98 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this this is insane
oh look at Fabby exhausting every last
resource the battles will be Electric
ity the moves will be fast it's game
over it's winning oh my God he's gonna
make a queen the stakes will be high he
just grabs his head he can't believe it
he just gave away the pawn the 2022
speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
it is Thursday morning and that means it
is time for an SCC double header two
amazing mattress coming your way today
and I have the honor of commentating the
first one alongside the one and only
International Master Levy Rosman Levy
good morning to you it's early what
better way to start and with a nice
juicy little SCC match
yeah the only alternative would be uh
probably a cgc match but if we're just
going to throw a bunch of acronyms
around this is probably second best it's
great to be here with you once again I
did have my coffee you have not and for
the sake uh of the commentators I hope
we get as much crazy excitement as we
get in matches like sarin vs giri uh but
obviously the players nervous systems
will definitely not hold up if that's
going to be the case well I popped open
some iced tea it said it had caffeine in
it then I realized it's only 15
milligrams that ain't gonna cut it so
the chest better be interesting but
we're getting ahead of ourselves let's
start with the main question what is at
stake what is the price well the prize
pool is an even 100 G's in every match
the winner earns 2 000 American dollars
and then 2 000 more is split based on
win percentage which means even if the
match outcome is decided there is still
plenty of money to go around based on
how many games you win and of course the
winner advances to the quarterfinals but
we'll get to that let's take a look at
the bracket and see who thus far has
advanced to the round of eight Levy it's
really A Feast for the eyes top right
you have Carlson caruana that's going to
be quite an interesting matchup coming
up what catches URI as we review the
bracket in the SEC thus far I didn't
even realize that they're that close to
each other and will play so quickly
that's amazing just a casual World Chess
Championship re rematch the only time
that Magnus uh never actually managed to
win a game in a uh in a classical
portion of a World Championship uh a lot
of things catch my eye I mean it's been
incredibly close aronian and draken we
had nehalogiri two matchups decided by
the final game and we can only hope for
more excitement today but uh I don't
know I don't know if we're gonna get as
much excitement today because it's a
fascinating storyline between these two
players so and a history as well so it
really is it really is there's nothing
more interesting than a fresh matchup
and that's what we have for you today
something fresh something relatively new
Wesley so takes on notorbeck abdusitorov
in the first of our SEC double header
now they have played before and the
fascinating wrinkle is that they've
actually played in the SEC two years ago
when Wesley so defeated notorbeck
convincingly but since then Notre big
has put together an unbelievable resume
he's won a minor tournament called the
world rapid Championship uh he's done
pretty decently in the Fisher random
World Championship
uh Levy I think it's safe to say we're
talking about a slightly different
motorbeck this time around
we are my only concern when I think
about nojerbek uh showing up to this
event is will it be the Story of gukesh
All Over Again young promising uh chess
player who really has made a massive
push in Rapid Blitz and classical but
over the board and that's actually I
mean in many ways being a better player
over the board than online is something
very commendable means your nervous
system is good your Poker Face is good a
lot of your a lot of the things you need
to succeed in chess are good but does
that translate to a high stakes online
chess event I don't know and we just saw
Wesley so win the cgc so he knows a
thing or two about online high stakes
chess events uh I'm not sure what's
gonna happen today right he's got the
he's the only guy that's ever beaten
Dodger back in the SEC but no jailbreaks
only played ever one ever match so
Wesley just has that way of putting
players to shame and just destroying
them and Wesley certainly has been
putting in hours and hours of practice
on chess.com so it's a big question
which we will explore before we jump
into the match let's discuss some
Logistics starting with the format the
SEC is a 16 player knockout some of the
players have already been knocked out
players score points across three
different time controls until the
three-hour ticker runs out and in the
event of a matched High there are four
games of one plus one and if that side
we have an Armageddon we've already had
a tie break we had one yesterday and we
have already well we have not yet had an
Armageddon but I'm keeping my fingers
crossed the SEC just has a way of being
a gift that keeps on giving the time
control itself uh involves 90 minutes of
five plus one followed by an hour of
three plus one and the match concludes
with 30 minutes of bullet and we have
seen time and time again uh Levy a lot
of these matches really do come down to
the bullet don't be fooled by the fact
that it's you know just 30 minutes and
we saw that yesterday how excited were
you to see Anisha Geary erasing a
three-point lead against none other than
nihal sarin that was incredible that was
incredible I was running errands all day
and I booted up the SEC match and I was
just watching the bullet for the last
like 30 40 minutes it was just I was so
tense and every game is on a knife's
edge and there's never a comfortable
moment in the bullet either you're like
oh why does window oh white is losing
it's just literally you're good
positions last like two seconds and then
it's all over but is noisier back the
guy that you think will stage a comeback
I don't know in many in many ways
advantages fall I think into Wesley so's
lap in this matchup wouldn't you say
like if he's down going into the bullet
probably gonna bet on Wesley to make a
comeback right because he's just he's
just that guy he's just that guy the
nervous system is there the online
playing experience is there or will
nojerbread just shut us up and just show
up and be like no my skill translates to
online as well I'm not sure I think he's
that guy but more importantly smarter
chess thinks Wesley is that guy smarter
chess is predicting that a comeback will
be unnecessary he's assigning Wesley a
two-point lead after five plus one a
very convincing victory in the three
plus one and he believes that Wesley
will cap it off with an 18 and a half
nine and a half match victory that is
incredibly bold I think the win
probability
88 that's really really generous Levy
I've been a lot more likely to agree
with smarter chess this time around
because hey I learned my lessons but
this seems real bold I think Notre back
might have a couple things to say about
this prediction do you were you doing
the commentary on the match Carlson
gukesh uh yes I was was the smart was
the smarter chess even more vicious
there it was even more vicious and even
more accurate yeah yeah well I don't
know how accurate it's this time but I
mean 888 12 is that's violent that is
the second largest lopsided margin that
we've had thus far I believe I mean I
don't know what the Carlson one was I
just remember tuning into that match and
going oh my god
um but again like that could happen
something tells me it won't I don't know
I don't know just I have a premonition
all right I just don't think that we're
gonna see such a lopsided score line but
that is basically their previous score
line it was 1810 so this time you just
take away half a point from noisy back
and give it to Wesley give it to Wesley
and it's anything is possible I think
this match is a big just black box I
could see this going many different ways
um you know the community also giving
Wesley The Edge but I think it's
important to point out that we shouldn't
necessarily lump uh Notre back and go
cash in the same category norterbeck is
a lot more of a practiced online player
he doesn't play as much on chess.com as
Wesley so but he's put in the hours
online he's no stranger to online events
so Levy I think just conceptually
norderbeck is going to feel more at ease
as this match gets underway than Gucci
was and by the way 79 of you predicted
Wesley so to win great to see thousands
upon thousands filling out your brackets
yeah and for another big chess event uh
in in a row I make a note to fill out a
bracket and then forget I I mean it's
just it's just beyond reprehensible
Behavior by myself and I'm very
frustrated I actually really wanted to
fill out a bracket
um behind closed doors in the chess.com
Global Championship uh you know staff
rooms we were debating who were the
favorites to win this event we were
ranking from 1 to 16 who are the
favorites and then I'm an idiot and I
never actually managed to fill out my
bracket obviously in this matchup I do
give the nod to Wesley do I give it to
the extent of doubling the score of
Notre back I don't know but you know
going back and I know we're about to get
the games underway but going back to
that like that point about bullet one
one plus one is such a weird format it's
so strange because like a long Blitz
game but you start with a minute on the
clock and yesterday we saw a niche who
might not traditionally be the guy that
you think about as like an excellent
bullet player just destroying nehal who
like is a top five 1-0 player in the
world probably right so anything can
happen and maybe today noji back will be
the guy who just shocks the world with a
little one plus one domination I don't
know
yeah I mean it's just so hard to figure
out flaws in Wesley's game but insofar
as you can get Wesley to feel
uncomfortable he's not the biggest fan
of time scrambles still in between
matches at the cgc Wesley was playing
for hours on chess.com I had the
pleasure of facing him in a couple of
matches and I have to say he's gotten
not just a lot faster but a lot more
accurate in time scrambles Wesley is now
good with the mouse he no longer has
obvious flaws in his Blitz and bullet
game and that honestly to me just makes
him such a scary opponent the fact that
he really doesn't have holes in his
classical game and now he's eliminated
most of his holes in the context of
Blitz and bullet as well so he is just
the Ultimate Nightmare SCC opponent
oh yeah your opponent just has
absolutely zero flaws yeah good luck
yeah he's he's good when there's a lot
of time on the clock he's good when
there's no time on the clock he's good
when there's a lot of pieces or no
pieces exactly it's just good he's just
really good I it's true I I mean I I
think Wesley's probably a top three lock
maybe top four like pre-event right you
talk Magnus Hikaru Wesley nihal that's
probably the top four to win the event I
don't know if it's in that order or in
what order probably depends on how they
wake up and what they had for breakfast
on the day of the finals exactly uh
I
I I'm very curious to see how this
develops I mean I mean this matches
gonna be super close I think it is and
we are ready to start the games I think
Wesley so as the higher seed we'll have
the white pieces in game one we remind
you that we will start with 90 whole
minutes of five plus one action you can
see the players on camera there Wesley
so Notre back with a pensive expression
on his face just a beautiful background
I could admire note robek's background
for years but okay we are off to the
races The Gong has sounded yes that was
sarcasm end surprise surprise Levy in
Italian in game one by Wesley
yeah we're going to be seeing a lot of
V4 e5s definitely definitely in the bull
in the uh Blitz portion I don't know
once this match gets
gets uh crazy you know uh I'm not sure
okay h6a5 this is definitely a system
and Castles by black now
you're gonna give us a little a little
bit of that G5 attacking stuff or is
that a little too spicy for game one
yeah too spicy for game one I think he's
gonna play more conservatively there's
that Bishop E6 move we all know and love
Bishop B5 very common response and white
was actually threatening to snap up a
piece with D4 and D5 that's why you need
to get this bishop off of C5
yeah there's a Spanish line right where
black plays Queen B8 Queen A7 or
something like that but not here but
that's a that's that's also an idea
looks very dumb but it's not I promise
because they play it
they do I mean Hikaru I think was kind
of the originator of this whole A5
Shenanigans I've also seen the Knight
dropping back to A7 here it makes
probably less sense just because of
Bishop A4 and I never know when I've got
the white side of these types of
positions like when to play D4 whether
to play Knight G3 or Bishop E3 there's
just a lot of buttons that you can press
and if you press these buttons in the
wrong order you can be worse with either
caller here
yeah you really could be there's a
a game I I analyzed recently in this
variation in this exact variation I
think it was um
it was the Eric ice in the hall game and
yeah there was this Knight A7 idea it
was from the um
it was from their their their Tata steel
rabbit and Blitz and uh it was it was a
wild wild game but we're not seeing that
now we're seeing something totally
different
uh yeah D4
yeah D4 Bishop drives back to D3
visually I really like White's position
but sadly that's not how chess is played
you still have to like make moves is
black going for the black's not going
exactly for Knight H5 Knight F4 is he
well Wesley's reaching back I don't know
if someone's
bothering Wesley over there or what's
going on but maybe it's his cat
Ah that's true but our cats a bother you
think do cats talk to at like face level
I don't thinks that was kind of a Half
Baked proposal uh but it's it's early in
the morning and Notre back in the
meantime he is taking the first sort of
long think of the game I agree I think
Wesley's already slightly better
you know when white plays D4 in this
position positions the bishop on D3
that's the most that white can normally
squeeze out of this type of position and
Notre back follows the levy Rosman
approach 985 on the board trying to whip
up some King side activity with Knight
H4 and Knight hr4 and queen F6 oh Wesley
just immediately plays Bishop C2 I was
trying to make all sorts of things work
by moving my F3 Knight because the
Knight on H5 is loose but uh well Wesley
played that move in less than a second
so I'm not even going to go back and
analyze you know it's one of those
things a guy plays a movie like all
right he's right I'm wrong
certain people uh that definitely
applies to Knight takes C5 is still not
a threat I think the reason why uh was
that black and play de5 and then ed4 but
we're past that that ship has sailed
Wesley continuing to Blitz out his moves
is Notre back going to position his
Queen on F6 yes he does
I'd be scared to have this with white
but Wesley I'm sure has probably
analyzed this as far back as like 2013.
yeah Bishop E3 I was gonna say keep the
center stable and is the F3 Knight going
to H2 is that we want some Knight H2
Knight G4 stuff or is there some Bishop
takes H3 and oh no there isn't but
yeah you gotta watch for that Knight G2
Bishop H3 but given the current assembly
of Black's pieces I don't think there
are any tactics I actually think Notre
back might be preparing a D5 strike in
the event moves away should I play D5
here with white with the idea of Bishop
E3
oh that's what it's showing let's bring
up our first analysis Board of the day
D5 perfect opportunity for that
bang bang and you've got both of the
miners saying black and Sack on H3 or
whatever but obviously you don't get
enough compensation here
so that means after D5 black would have
had to move the bishop and allowed the
destruction of his Pawn structure the
bishop takes B6 but
uh Levy Wesley waited for you to say
that and decided to put his Knight on F5
instead
right because in that line I think the
the Black Knight on F4 is just way too
strong and oh both guys got their knives
knife F4 knife F5 whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
he gives up H3 with check
uh evolvar was like have you woken up
yet Wesley
can you just okay obviously you can take
and just go back to G5 but uh can you
take and go back to F4 can you take and
not even move the Knight yeah you and go
like D5 there now I think Wesley's idea
shines through after Knight H3 King G2
Knight G5 actually let's just bring up
another analysis word as neuterbeck
contemplates his next move I think here
White's idea works like a charm take
stakes and queen G4 Levy and the pawn on
G5 can't really be defended yeah Queen
H5 is probably even better
yeah I was thinking like just go
Checkmate yeah Queen H5 right but look
at what Notre Beck has done he hasn't
even touched the H3 Pawn you
it looks like it's happened right now
can you go so what was the best line
after after uh was it Knight H3 and what
was it back to it was D5 it was Knight
H3 King G2 and then D5 just blasting
down in the center
and White's position collapses here
because if you take the Knight after d
take C4 you lose the Knight on F5 with
interest no this is a disaster for white
that was such a expert Bluff by Wesley
oh my God photo Bluff oh my goodness and
instead
he's Desperado sacked on H6 recovered
the Knight on D5 and now his Knight's
heading for G4 and he's right as rain
wow that was spectacular I mean he
played it with such confidence yeah
exactly I uh I was like in shock that's
very interesting that the Knight can go
to H3 and just die but in the time it
takes White's King to take the Knight
King escapes beyond the walls of the
castle and uh it's very dangerous stuff
it's crazy even this position looks
completely horrible for why it's just so
passive but it's not it's like very good
the Black Knight on G6 can't do much and
the pawn on H6 and the weak black king
are kind of an issue
and I know it's still very very early in
the matchroom this is literally game one
the score is zero zero but these types
of opportunities have to be exploited
and the last thing notrebec wants is to
get off to you know an o304 start
because Wesley is just not known to
relinquish those types of leads so a big
Miss right there in game one for an odor
back if you had seen D5 he would have
won that game that position was just a
total disaster for white
it's also funny if that was a bullet
game he would have taken on H3 in a
second no question like it's just it's
just so different it's like game one
five plus one you're like oh my
opponent's not gonna blunder
3 and some tactic but in bullet you're
like what he hung upon yeah you don't
have any time to think twice about it I
don't know you break down to
down to seconds here this is a very
common
mistake to make and I've made it myself
five plus one and three plus one are
just such odd formats you're like I
always get a second I don't have to I'm
not I'm never gonna flag
doesn't feel good to leave yourself with
10 seconds against two minutes just
doesn't feel good
yeah neither does your king side Knight
coming to G4 Queen coming to H5 at this
point White's position basically plays
itself I would start with Queen H5
using the fact that Bishop takes D4
doesn't work takes takes and Bishop
takes G6 and your minor pieces collapse
in the end ugh
yeah the only thing you have to decide
here with white is like are you okay
winning a pawn but going to an end game
that could be drawable or do you want to
keep as many pieces on the board as
possible because black only has 15
seconds
at this point I think you try to keep
the Queens on the board maybe you just
throw in Rook a to D1 just in case to
protect the D4 upon those seven seconds
how is Notre by coping to hold this
together he tries to get his Knight
around to F5
his only target is that D4 Pawn but
you know you can't exactly build your
career over attacking that pawn Wesley
though taking the Slow Roll approach
Wesley though and also Wesley so Bishop
yeah
it's just 924 and God it's a dreadful
situation if you have to give up this
bishop then just look at those light
squares on the king side and the dark
squares
like Bishop on B6 was just a spectator
it just sort of stood around didn't get
ever get a chance to play whoa Wesley
taking on F5 I thought Knight G4 was
just game
he's trying to be he's trying to be
simple about it uh and I don't know I
don't know how simple you can be here
yeah ah there's got to be a win there's
got to be a win looks like Bishop G5
ends the game and then drop your queen
back to make space for the night yikes
yeah when H5 is just literal 1-0 on the
spot yeah Knight H6 is Unstoppable
there it is and that's oh Bishop H6 Bing
wow yeah and noise back has that look
like well let's forget that game ever
happened this is the this is a tough
moment like when you when you lose or
you win the first game and
oh we have another e45 this time of
Spanish Wesley gonna go for a
Berlin and now we see 4d3 Auntie Berlin
I'm gonna have a lot of this in this
match we're gonna have Italian
alternating with re Lopez kind of like
the Wesley hikara match from the cgc but
if you had looked at that game just via
a bunch of diagrams you would have been
forgiven for thinking that it was a
super smooth effort by Wesley just kind
of a vintage classic Wesley game but if
you look more carefully there was that
crazy moment when noderbeck was flat out
winning if he had grabbed the pawn on H3
so that's both a good thing and the bad
thing right maybe Wesley isn't in as
good of tactical form as he normally is
but on the other hand maybe ignorance is
bliss maybe it's better for Notre pick
not to know what kind of a chance he had
in game one
and if there was coaching allowed like
they do in basketball where the coach
can yell out or play and you go all
right I got it or exploit this def you
know if your coach could be like by the
way he blundered horribly with G3 he'd
be like oh I had a chance I wonder if
not your break is just sitting there
like I just got obliterated I never had
any chance in that game uh obviously
these players have different emotional
kind of balance imbalance so he might
just be like all right I'm gonna try my
best with white now but just knowing
that your opponent totally messed that
up for a move is a big plus to
self-confidence moving forward he's got
he's got to strike back quickly you
can't let it get away like you said
Wesley's not gonna relinquish a
three-point lead for sure and I like the
way notrebec is approaching this game
very aggressive G2 G4 is on the board is
he playing too aggressively well the
eval bar certainly thinks so and Wesley
says get off me he goes G6 again this
time there's no Pawn on H6 to capture
and not Rebecca has to bring his Knight
back but Levy a lot of holes on the king
side that you're creating with that move
G4
96 I mean when you go wow I would have
never in a million years played A5 and
the craziest thing is the the eval
stayed the same which means that it was
one of the best moves that's so
ridiculous like
it's A5
he's playing on the king well he's
playing on the queen side he's also kind
of playing on the king side he's opening
up the bishop of course I can't draw
that Arrow uh but you get the point guys
like playing G4 King H1 looking to
Checkmate you you're like Yay 5b5
exactly
and that's a very hard move to face
because if white trades oh my God that
is not how the night that is not of the
pawn moves if white trades then he
rectifies Black's Queen Side Pawn
structure if you don't trade well then
what do you do do you play B3 and allow
black to isolate your a pawn
I wish I could do that just push a bunch
of Queen side pawns and suddenly you're
losing
well not you don't push the pawns and
are losing your opponent your opponent
is losing yeah yes yes I I can push a
bunch of funds and be losing it's really
not so complicated
um but uh yeah wow I mean so will noji
break ever actually play Rook G1 or H4
did he just play G4 and he's like Yep
this is my life now I just have a Pawn
on G4 yeah I really wish I have a
question for you if you offered knows
you're back like you you said hey you
can bribe Wesley with a sum of money to
put the pawn back on G2 or G3 like what
do you think his his ceiling is how much
money what's the risk reward
that I mean I think he would give money
in order to bring his Pawn back to G3
although I guess that's what you're
saying that's what I'm saying like what
is the ceiling two thousand dollars like
you know what's this five grand prize
two two grand because that's what you
get for winning an SEC match that's what
he would accept
for bringing the pawn back to G3 but
right now Wesley is kind of combining
two different operations at once he's
playing against the weak King side
squares so he might put a nine and a
half four and he has this idea of going
Bishop D7 and queen E8 which I think
ultimately is the reason why he
initiated you know that entire Queen
side operation but on the other hand
you've got the corresponding weakness on
A5 and the corresponding idea of white
going Queen E1 so interesting play here
on both sides of the board for both
players
yes
yes it is Knight D4 looks super nice
yep that Knight Is Anchored In by two
pawns and a queen and in many ways like
sometimes you run a position like this
through a computer for White and the
computer doesn't know your history so it
doesn't know that you played King H1
Rook G1 G4 it doesn't know that you lost
the first game of a match it's just like
you should not attack here it's very bad
if you attack just don't attack maybe
you'll draw this game right and as a
human it's very difficult to do that if
you've already played King H1 Rook G1 G4
like you can't go back you've waited
three hours in line for the roller
coaster you might as well just go now
right like so you just go G5 or
something like that and that might
backfire so I I don't know well noji
back actually successfully Implement any
sort of action or will the game be
decided on the queen side taking the
pawns unfortunately looking like that
Knight C4 does I mean obviously create
the threat if Bishop takes A5 now Wesley
can do a bunch of different things I
like a move like Bishop E6 essentially
saying go take my Pawn I mean clearly
notorbeck isn't in the mood to take
Wesley's Pawn sacrifices but maybe
you're just playing the center Bishop B6
and queen D7 and try to over extend
white on the queen side if you are
intent on defending A5 you can play the
move C6 and maybe even Rook F to A7 if
necessary later on Wesley he's learned
his lesson from the previous game he's
like I'm not giving anything away any
anymore
C6 Rook A7 is such a ridiculous idea
only in Wesley's games Knight takes D4
wow committal move allowing black to
rectify his Pawn structure with CD
yeah CD if Edie there was some F4 ideas
I mean there might still be a four ideas
Queenie one wow no no no just going for
the pawn just that's I mean we might see
Rook fa7
that's absurd I kind of said it jokingly
honestly and now I realize it's a
totally legitimate move we might see it
and we are we do
yeah that's that's why he's the third
ranked player in the event in the cgc
champion and I'm looking at this like I
would have just chucked the pawn like
you can't actually hold on to the Vaughn
I mean it's like he's playing tug of war
like in you know in uh in first second
grade he's like no that's mine you can't
have it I'm not sharing and they there's
that four I mean it looks the plan looks
clear as they for white no
yeah but the problem is that your your
foundations are very kind of squeaky
here black is now threatening another
bad Arrow Bishop takes C4 forcing the
Knight back away to D2 and Wesley's just
got a lot of real estate on the queen
side that he can occupy and he's already
occupying it Rook B7 you've got ideas
like C5 C4 and black is just so
fundamentally sound on the king side
Levy that the moment white plays G5 he
might stand to lose in the event that
the Center opens up G5 can be met with
F5 look at those light squares I don't
like the way this is going for Notre
back actually
yeah exactly right I I had mentioned
this once you commit to G4
I mean you can't play an end game
because in all end games black has sort
of just survived there with this light
squared bishop and you're right you're
right that diagonal to the king is
brutal the white king in the corner is
not safe no no no
that's he's just not safe any pawn you
push forward G or E immediately weakens
light squares just as you said
um I would go H3
yeah seriously it's time to play defense
and King H2 and now the king is actually
kind of safe and then maybe cluster up
further by doubling Rooks on the g-fall
although let's not forget that A4 Pawn
is in the crosshairs of the black queen
so you know that might come back to
White to bite you know who's going to
take it Wesley Wesley's absolutely going
to take it he's gonna Wes is the kind of
guy to go Rook before and he does and he
says give me that a pawn
it's gone it's just brutal he can't
defend it oh
and you're weakening the long diagonal I
mean this is already desperation here
from motorbike I don't dislike E5 I
think this is what he's got to try
and Wesley just Bishop G7
yeah he just defends everything
he defends
and after Bishop D5
there is going to be hell to pay on the
light squares
yeah at least now the white king can go
to H2 right at least when it was on H1
it was really miserable
but Wesley's gonna take on A4 he's going
to come back with his Queen and he's
going to push his a pawn and that is how
he's going to win this game and F5
another excellent move the moment white
positions his Rook on E1 he shuts down
the e-file he shuts down the king side
and you're absolutely right rooked after
the Apon disappears black just closes
his eyes and pushes his own a pawn so
motorbeck has to create something on the
king side but what
he's trying white uh what a black can
just play like I'm thinking some H6 or
even just Bishop E6 back and Bishop D5
like just he took it F5 and just go back
what's the problem because there's a
great move I was gonna say if there's
one man on Earth to take on F5 with the
bishop and then just go back and go just
whoop whoop just take an extra step it's
Wesley I'm holding my pen like this is
how it's like very instructional you
know what's it just like exactly yeah
is it the bishop back to E6 and you know
yeah it's like when uh I had access to
the clicker in school
you know arrow and everybody loved it oh
my gosh yeah see this is the the stuff
that the Grandmasters who get
homeschooled miss out on all right we
actually went to school all right well
I'm not a great mess but you know you
you went to school yeah we got to like
you know remember those days we had a
substitute teacher we had the TV wheeled
into the room the TV and the movie that
was one of the good days that's what
that was the small Pleasures in life it
would just make your day now I need like
Netflix and popcorn and bed and you know
seven different Pleasures or an SEC
match you know that'll do it for me
Wesley just needs the pawn on H3 he has
picked up his pawn and um E6 though
Rook B1 check
ah that would have won the pawn in the
end Notre back
okay but now the queen comes back to E6
and Here Comes The Rook to B1 I think
Wesley's taking this one yeah he again
knows your back had to be faster there
with the counter play right seemed like
he had to play E6 just kind of go for it
because now
no yeah Wesley doesn't even have to
hurry just take a G5 start pushing your
king side majority
yep no way he plays Rook before right
now before he clearly has had his
breakfast today
no way he's just gonna play Rook before
I take his Pawn you know Wesley's the
type of guy like Wesley's Wesley's wave
oh my God oh my gosh he's so naughty
like he just like how does he do this
hey Queen defend like you do all the
defending and the queen says okay no
problem now The Rook comes back you can
come back to B6 to B8
just took the pawn and went back and now
he's gonna win after Rook f8 he's just
oh my God
yeah let's game over Rook F1
oh oh another effect free moving Rook up
one he thought Wesley was gonna go Rick
off one check
wow Wesley went Rook before Rook A4 Rook
B4 Rook B8 Rook f8 Rook F2 Checkmate
that's what happened unbelievable it's
already 2-0 and that to me was a far
more dominant display than game one that
was such a smooth game the way he
exploited notrex moved G4
like the way he just squeeze through on
the king side and combine it with play
on The Queen side we take that stuff for
granted but Wesley's one of the only
people in the world who can do that with
such regularity that was an amazing game
that was just a perfect perfect display
of his skill set just so good
understanding what move to make at the
right moment when to get greedy when to
take a step back
just amazing amazing stuff there no
jailbreak has to get on the scoreboard
like now I mean anytime's a good time to
get on the scoreboard in the SEC
but right now it would be really nice
even to draw I think a solid draw would
go a very long way toward improving his
confidence making him realize that hey I
don't have to lose every game in this
match against Wesley and they are
repeating the same line from game one
Wesley's like okay fine I won the first
game not cool not quite because The
Bishop's on A7 right I don't know it was
on B6 uh-huh yeah which I I hate to be
that guy and be like well you know it's
once no because I think the whole of the
ideas are different right like now C6 B5
is some idea like I
I don't know
yeah as commentators are supposed to say
they're pluses and minuses
yes oh Knight H7 okay so the Knight
takes a different route this time other
time it went Knight H5 Knight F4 this
time he plays Knight H7 Knight G5 these
openings are so absurd there's so many
different ideas and move orders
yeah it's just crazy how complicated it
is conceptually and the idea of Knight
G5 is twofold in the event of the trade
that pod on G5 is a very strong attacker
can move into G4 it also anchors in the
Knight on F4 but the second idea is that
you're loosening up White's control over
the D4 Pawn so in the event of the
nitrate black will be threatening he
takes D4 and Bishop takes D4 don't
forget about that Bishop hiding over
there in the corner
I know it was on B6 now it's even
further away which makes it much harder
to see obviously even though it's
technically on the same diagonal board
is Big soon it's going to be next to
notorbeck's camera I'm like it's just
gonna move even further but it's gonna
just glitch off the map Hey listen
chess.com social media team loves meming
around during these events so that
Bishop should just glitch off the map
like you know the shooting stars mean
[Music]
just they have a Teleport all right
Bishop's gonna go further and further
off the board
um but unfortunately they code chess
boards to have borders so like if you
actually tried to get the bishop off it
wouldn't work ridiculous yeah yeah I
don't know why that's so lame
put in the laws of physics or gravity
onto a chessboard but that night has
come back by the way it's back to G5 it
is and now decision time for Wesley
because you could just leave the Knight
on F3 but he decides to take
and what's his follow-up
what
two very positional he wants I think
Bishop G4 playing for the light squares
again
actually very impressive idea
what
wow Bishop E2 I would have
I would have not played that move I'm
not gonna lie to you I don't
like why didn't you go Knight G3 like
like Knight G3 and Knight F5 wow I guess
Knight G3 Knight F4 and what he was
saying is that the bishop on D3 had kind
of overstayed its welcome
now he's also making it more difficult
for black to push F5 for black to do
anything productive on the king side I
actually really like this idea and maybe
I'm over the spell
when I when I say I wouldn't have played
it it doesn't mean because I had a
better idea I'm just I'm just showing my
own limitations as a human and I guess
there's also G3 now that gets enabled
like King H2 and then G3 in some
positions and you can at least kick out
Hey Wesley hasn't uh been stopped from
playing Chief just because the H3 punt
is hanging doesn't mean he's not gonna
play G3 he's going to take a page out of
game one Knight H2 instead so we have
this weird kind of cat and mouse game
who flinches first with regards to the
Bishops Wesley says okay take my Bishop
so I can activate my knight
is there like G3 now is that insane G3
oh oh I was thinking take take Queen H5
but uh then D4 hangs in some lines I
guess but and then I was thinking
Checkmate on the H file but I don't know
I guess I had greater greedier
intentions I think Wesley's calculating
just that right now G3 Knight takes H3
King G2 line doesn't end there there's
Queen H6 but I think you can snap that
Knight off the board Bishop takes E6 and
queen G4 I can show that line G3 I think
we're gonna see G3
King G2
Queen H6 trying to defend the Knight but
now Bishop takes E6 and the bishop is
replaced by the queen
wait here there's nina forchuk not so
fast
I guess Knight G4 and Rook H1 is the way
to do it yeah yeah this wins the game
well the queen has to go to like H7 oh
my God
okay maybe maybe Queen absolutely very
patient move and then okay
is laughing at me but when is it not
laughing at me is should but can't white
also start with D5 like Ken Wesley wait
but that didn't happen
we have some moves yeah Queen to D2 so
he went the other way
he did not play g3 at all did not play
G3 I think he's gonna go for your idea
on push D5
well let's just walk up the center says
more about him than me man I'm I'm just
I I did I did like G3 I don't know why
he didn't go for it it looked it looked
very natural but he's also up 2-0 so he
can do what he wants
yeah look natural it looks concrete I
think he's looking for like the perfect
opportunity to play G3 the problem is
now it's harder to get that move in
because after Knight takes H3 black can
solidify the Knight with G4
still I like I like White's position
here I think he's slightly better
I'm just I'm so perplexed because just
to me it was so natural to keep the
White Queen on D1 and fighting for the
light squares but I guess like on D2 I
just don't understand the role of the
queen seems like this is Wesley's idea
just take a huge amount of space
um it's fascinating how Levy and in at
least two of these first three games
he's he's using both sides of the board
I think that's one of the most
impressive skills at the top level how
seamlessly they're able to transition
from playing on the king side something
I struggle with like when I'm playing on
one side of the board my eyes are
fixated to that side but Wesley just
throws in a couple casual Queen side
moves and then goes back to the king
side yeah but it's wow and he does just
completely give up that pawn he's not
worried about the anchor
he will with Queen E2
and you know like in many ways black is
sort of Frozen right now his his Rook on
A7 I mean bad his Rook on E8 not bad but
just doesn't have the same impact on the
game what about even like
F3 I mean is that too risky yeah Queen
E2 I guess completely fine I think
Wesley's just too attracted to this idea
of playing Queen takes G4 and in the
event of an end game again White's the
only one who holds all of the cards in
fact white doesn't just have an idea of
going C5 eventually many moons later but
also the idea of doubling down on the H
file Rook H1 Rook H drive and you can
get checkmated easily if you're the
black king yes and this is a pivotal
moment in this game from dodgerberg if
he wants to salvage half a point he has
to knock it down too low he has to yeah
I was gonna say he has to not get low on
time and uh
he's trending in that direction right
now he is because he sees the
possibility of Queen takes G4 he sees
how bad the end game is
and of course Wesley could also play
Knight takes G4
but how can you resist the temptation to
pin the Knight like this
yeah I I don't know if I'd be able to A4
is a double-edged sword man because it's
a restricting move but that pawn very
easily could just perish rookie three
Rook a three in some end games rookie
three four Rook E3 is a gray move that's
a Wesley move right there good call
and yeah now the question is which way
he's gonna go it's just a good
Improvement well okay it's very risky
very risky Roxy one
Roxy one
I don't know about this whole operation
by Notre back he's trying to create
Queen side counter play catching white
sleeping while his Rook is still passive
but it might be a little bit too slow
yeah but he's trying to catch white
sleeping but all four of his important
pieces are sleeping like exactly like
none of his pieces can move I I don't
know how he's
C5 like nah too much too much I wouldn't
even sacrifice I don't know Wesley is
not gonna play C5 he just plays Rook C1
so Notre back wants to take and go Rook
B7 and quickly pile up on this B2 Pawn
that's is that strategy going to be
successful that's the question
can white just play like B4
definitely or rookie two yeah of course
of course he brought the Rook out to E3
but now he just brings it back to E2
okay so we're okay B7
and does he want Rook C to C2 or does he
have something more violent in mind
um I think he has to play that right
because
I'm a little bit worried about the look
of Rook before in that position I'm also
worried about motorbike's clock this is
a complicated position he's got 30
seconds left
hmm
no Rooks Rook C2 Rook before yeah F3
Maybe
I mean you could also take on A4
and at the end of the line you have a
nasty backrank check on A8 and then you
can follow it up with Queen H4 check but
then Queen yeah it's not over
and after Queen H6 suddenly White's got
all these weaknesses in the center he's
got to deal with oh I'm getting nervous
20 seconds for knows you're back and
about 40
for Wesley Wesley got to decide what
he's doing here is he gonna put the foot
on the gas or relax Rook B2
I think he's gonna go takes a knight F3
just try to get as many pieces off the
board as possible
I think Knight F3 is an important
resource here actually
I think I think you kind of have to do
it I don't know I don't know what else
you could play and he plays it oh
Wesley's just so accurate in these
positions
okay there's like Rook A8 Queen H3 queen
of Queen H3 Queen F5 dude there is a
draw now if I'm Wesley I'm playing for a
win I'm playing Queen takes F3 and
trying to keep my chances alive but I
think Wesley's saying hey I'm up two
points I don't need to take any
unnecessary risk I'm gonna go for the
drop he's so he's got a sense of humor I
predicted the Wesley sequence he's not
taking the night because the night's not
going anywhere full draw
yeah Queen F5 but he he might he might
play this for a win he might take on F3
and just try to keep going but I doubt
it because of Rook B4 there I think
that's the specific reason he's got to
go for the draw now you could trade
Queens here but I think he's gonna give
no Rebecca pass
yeah
oh that's it
wow
on the board
I gotta tell you I uh I I feel I feel
like a proud kid you know uh who like
got a couple hits at his baseball game
when I predict the sequence that Wesley
plays
hey that was that was impressive Queen
H3 those retreating moves are not easy
to spot
but I like the psychology and the
decision making for Wesley up two points
he's not somebody who just takes risks
you know randomly
no he's not do you realize that the
position was sharp enough and this time
I don't believe that we are going to be
seeing any G4 action here he goes again
with his A5 move yeah you white could
have played G4 no G4 makes no difference
okay now this time we have A5 A4 is he
still gonna go B5 that's not out of the
question entirely
no he doesn't because I guess it's too
loose it made sense when white was oh
okay he goes again
okay
see I'm going G4 though I mean the dark
scores are too weak I think he's learned
his lesson
yeah but you don't play King H1 without
some indication of I guess he's gonna go
G3 F4 is that the idea
I think eventually but I I'm just not
overly impressed with this setup for
Notre back Wesley's just so active here
and he's got no weaknesses and even if
you play F4 Levy he's gonna be like okay
he takes F4 thank you for the dark
squares in the center
oh careful now I thought that I thought
that blundered a fork for half a second
I did as well
so what F4 now looks very good
I think you have it might be a horrible
move I don't know but I I cannot see a
more natural look what three that the
baby version of f4 what does that do
what is the point of a three low rolling
it now he might be trying to go G3 and
F4 but even if he makes all of those
moves black just plays e takes F4 and
meets G takes F4 with F5 so
yeah I'm a little bit puzzled maybe he
wants to move his Queen into F2 into
position and then play F4
yeah I think that's it
wait is there Knight takes C2 no there
isn't I have been looking at that move
for so long
why isn't there Knight C2 I think it's
actually an instructive line okay let's
bring up an announce word really fast
Knight C2 Knight C2 Queen D3 if I'm
looking at this correctly white has 93.
ah Brooks are disjointed and more
importantly you take on d8 with check
and then you take f8 and take F2 but
we're trying to make them work but yeah
yeah so yeah Notre back continuing to
Slow Roll things with Rook a to D1
isn't equal
he's trying to slow roll the king of
slow rolls yeah I don't know about that
F5 Wesley's like you're not gonna play
out for you're not gonna eat the apple
I'm gonna give me
Wesley uh Wesley heard me say he's the
king of slow rules he's like oh yeah F5
immediately rips open the center
that's very risky positionally because
you're creating a weakness on E5 and now
I'm starting to like motorbike's
position I really don't know about F5
Knight D1 Knight C3 I mean White's
position looks it looks like karpov
would beat this beat every every chess
master of his day and age with this
position with white oh totally and
Bishop G6 runs into Knight G4 you could
lose that E5 Pawn in a heartbeat
I can't tell if Wesley was just
repositioning his head or shaking it
kind of like wobbled a tiny bit that was
the first sign of emotion in about 40
minutes of action here and I I don't
think he's that thrilled and the only
sign of emotion we're probably gonna get
for the rest of the match
yep that was it's not okay takes one of
five wow
sorry it's a big decision he wants
rookie for he's obviously just playing
against
this massive weakness on E5
yeah it's a very strange isolate upon we
very rarely see this just the
E5 Pawn completely isolated not a queen
spun
uh White blockades it white can put
every single one of his pieces to attack
it but can he win it is the question
that's the big question and that's the
where the principle of two weaknesses
originates because Wesley when necessary
can drop his Knight back to C6 and say
hey you know you finished the
architectural beautification of your
position but how are you actually going
to make progress as you said
yes I like that
artificial beautiful beautification wow
I don't know architectural
beautification but artificial would be a
better word there
it's uh it looks amazing position looks
super good problem is that's not
that's not how uh games work are you
drinking uh uh is that is that a lay
Croix I'm double fisting I've got a
coconut Lacroix and
a pomegranate green tea
artificially flavored beverage what if
you mix them
oh I'm a big guy I like add sparkling
water to everything ah yeah apple juice
sparkling water sparkling water makes
everything better
it really does
like this like this chess match you know
yeah well these guys uh where's no job's
King jug by the way remember when he was
used to be drinking uh out of a full jug
today he's got like yeah the boss glass
best enjoyed with the Lacroix and by the
way the scenario we described has
unfolded Wesley has dropped his Knight
back to C6
and move this queen up to G6 you can't
take on E5 because after the queen trade
you drop the Knight
where to from here
don't know H4
H5 white resigns
for H5 yeah Queen takes H5 906 I don't
care oh no I was saying H4 H5 and white
resigns oh wait 45 wins the night oh
that's crazy
it's like you're the second you try to
play oh my God yeah I mean like look at
this I mean
but by the way but is this the first
ever game in history where one guy has
all his pawns on light squares and the
other guy has all his pawns on dark
squares that's a crazy observation and
now that you mentioned that I can't take
my eyes off of it and probably chat's
the same way
no they're they just heard you say
double fisting and they don't know what
that means but they're still not over
that doesn't it mean like two hot dogs
you know like eating too it means to eat
things that it's yeah yeah it yeah it
means it means something normal but you
said Fist and you know yeah sure hate
added the good or this early in the
morning
yeah it's a little too early for that
the different different kind of double
fisting going on and it it involves it
putting uh
I was I cannot finish that sentence I'm
gonna um just don't dig yourself into a
hole chat's in a dangerous place right
now
I wonder who's gonna break this deadlock
of having pawns completely on opposite
complexes
yeah
I was gonna say is it even breakable I
don't think it is and to that point Levy
I'm sure you've seen your share of games
where the player who's quote unquote on
the better side gets frustrated and
overpresses and Wesley has won a ton of
games like that as well
yes
uh I am frequently on the other side of
a game like this I'm not on Wesley's
side C3 okay it's been broken
and uh
you can't take on B3 nope
yeah the seal the seal has been broken I
think you have to go back to C6
and now of course you don't have access
to the D4 square but conversely white
now has to deal with another weakness on
D3 which black can attack by shifting is
Rook to d8
and if there was one man on Earth two
very uh to be very opportunistic with
the targeting a weakness it's Wesley
yeah he sniffs those out a mile away
okay G6 visually this position looks
spectacular for white like it's
literally could not get any better maybe
you can play H4 just to complete the you
know king-size squeeze but literally
yeah the carpool would play H4
you would but where to from there I feel
like I run into this all the time you
make all the improving you're supposed
to have a win and you just don't like
where is the Breakthrough can you play
King G1 king of two King E2 King D2 King
C2 King B2 and then just play G for it
and attack
that's like the petrosion idea I love it
I think you should try it there's
literally nothing to lose get your king
to the queen side and go G4 oh my gosh
or just at least put the king like he's
doing it oh he's doing it I think he's
going King F1 he's just double checking
to make sure that he doesn't cross any
danger zones oh
this is such a satisfying moment for you
oh my God oh my gosh black might have
had Knight D4 check there in the middle
but anyway I I was like a bit worried
there was always a B5 or some sacrifice
oh my gosh she's actually gonna walk his
King and maybe play G4 he's doing it and
he's not afraid of Wesley playing B5
because Wesley cannot divert a single
piece from their defense of the E5 fund
that's why it's so bad to have a
weakness like this and there this is my
is my is my most accomplished moment as
a chess commentator ever ever No this is
so instructive oh my gosh
oh my hi guys you're gonna put this on
your Tick Tock Channel whatever uh got
some chess on everything except Levy
Rosman on Tick Tock you can follow me
there oh my gosh I'm so I'm I'm done man
this is my Peak I'm just never getting
better than this has to win dude
recommended
he's got a win though if he doesn't win
this game after that king walk this
match is over
oh it totally isn't I think he is
winning he's gonna go H5 and he's the
king now just away from the King side
you finally don't have to worry about
the drawbacks of a move like H5 there he
goes
Rook Cafe still not over yo how about
Rook F5
oh my God you're on an absolute role
right now holy smokes Rook F5 I don't
even I don't know if it's a good move or
not ah I would have played Rook oh God I
think it was a good movie goes rookie
three he instead switches back to
attacking the E5 Pawn so where's the win
okay Wesley goes Queen F6 he's trying to
trade Queens with Queen F2
is there H6
King takes H6 G5 oh my God
but you know you're right it's like the
two weakness concept the the weaknesses
now are E5 which has been a weakness the
whole game and now the king Black's King
is a weakness just exactly white
threatens just H takes G6 and Rook H2
Wesley desperately trying to whip up
counter Play It's Not Over Notre back
has 40 seconds Queen A1 is in the mix
oh he allowed The Rook to sneak into the
age file and now Rook H1 is going to be
super dangerous
I missed that how did he miss that Rook
H3
that almost traps the queen
oh okay
he's just giving up E5 completely it's
insane he's giving a B5 but the idea I
think is to meet rookie one with Rook F2
check that's actually a prophylactic
move and now it's a three result game
again
yeah 95 Rook H1 right oh my God too
that's just winning I think it's just
winning for black
holy smokes white could get mated after
all Nutter back down to eight seconds no
no you bet don't throw after getting
such a gr oh God
yeah Wesley trading Queens I think
there's still winning chances for white
here
maybe not many but there are King juice
E5 is just hanging right that's the
problem I think Notre back is going to
win this game actually
you do yep I'm gonna make a prediction
of my own
uh Wesley's in the time scramble right
so okay
it's just that I mean notorbeck's up
upon rookie seven is a threat okay
Wesley pulls out it's a draw here that
would be crazy
but he might
okay
I thought so too maybe Rook H1 Rook B1
but Wesley taking the more passive
approach
uh-oh oh but the king's gonna couldn't
the king have gone to C4 this also were
ah D4 nice move it's just with Black's
King cut off like that I feel like The
Rook is tasked with too many defensive
jobs at once
yep King walks around D5 D5 has to be
winning and then rookie six is a threat
looks like not your back's gonna get on
the board he is Wesley Flags but what a
game for Notre back it wasn't entirely
smooth at the end but Levy the idea of
marching the king to the queen side and
playing G4 I'd be proud to find that in
a classical game he found that in three
seconds but yes he did the gray Levy
Rosman on his side
yeah oh and I get uh now now he gets to
go to break on that huge win that's a
massive confidence boost for both myself
and for noserbeck uh the man whose last
name is so powerful it breaks the screen
barriers big comeback win and it almost
got away from him it's very important he
won that game to go into our first break
just the point behind Wesley let's match
on now
it most certainly is it's only a one
point match and you called it nothing
would have been more frustrating than
carrying out an effort that incredible
only to ruin it at the end uh he could
have got a big fat zero on the
scoreboard but instead he keeps his
composure he wins a critical game and
the match score is one and a half two
and a half folks we will take our first
break of this SEC match you are watching
the SEC double header the first match of
the day between Wesley and Notre back we
will be back with more SCC action on the
other side of this short break
any move can be the last you make
in a war of the mind you must adapt to
change
every mistake made an opportunity to
strength
check and when the ash is set on
will be crowned the victor
checkmate
Victory oh Jesus Christ
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship the score in the first
match of our double header between
Wesley and Notre Beck is two and a half
one and a half in Wesley's favor it's
been a pleasure commentating the match
so far alongside the one and only Gotham
chess Levy we've got an all we can eat a
frustrating last game for Wesley but I
just have to say the quality of Chess
this season in the SEC has been
incredible and this match has been no
exception thus far yeah it hasn't been
an exception at all it's been a
theoretical discussion a lot of very
interesting E4 E5 kind of games Concepts
middle game plans and ideas and it's
very important node direct got a win
there before the break I mean I really
just can't stress it enough there was a
legitimate chance we were looking there
that he might lose that game even just
get swindled somehow get frustrated but
credit to him for keeping his nerves and
not just even holding when the position
spawn out of control but honestly
winning with relative ease you called it
so one game match kind of a new match if
you will he's finally on the board and
um he's looking to put that 12 smarter
chess prediction to shame he is indeed
and the next game has begun and just
like that it got aborted so I don't know
what all of that is about I was about to
get super excited we might say another
Berlin I mean
yeah that was uh that was strange
um a little bit what happened there
maybe they're preventing Notre back from
playing E5 you were allowed to play any
move except E5
I know it's like those kind of matches
let's try again
uh
[Music]
you think they're gonna play E4 E5 even
in the bullet
I think so because Wesley used to be a
lot more versatile
uh in his Blitz Games but I think in the
last couple of months he's basically
been playing E4 exclusively just like
any time control he just sticks to his
guns
yeah he makes him a very annoying
opponent so we had um we had Bishop A7
plus okay this time we have Knight H7
preemptively careful now after Knight F1
D4 already is a threat
yes definitely look this up during the
break
I can't even tell I I'm forgetting who's
white and who's black uh no jailbreak is
playing Black because he just played
White
oh my gosh
a little Tabasco sauce added to the king
side there now the common reaction is he
takes F5 and strike at the center with
D4
and he does
um
yeah there you go
well I gotta predict a move here and
there
man Black's position looks so Airy
it that's actually the word that I was
thinking about as well it's just so
loose and there's so many weak diagonals
but I guess he wants to get away with it
maybe bring the Knight back to F6
whoa and I says or this game is a
perfect example of static versus Dynamic
play like black is weak everywhere we
King bad Central presence bad pieces
technically
but he just kind of like has a lot of
open lines obscure pressure on various
squares pieces and somehow isn't just
dead lost like somehow it just doesn't
make any sense but that's that's life
it's life it's modern chess for you and
what's interesting is that it's actually
not that easy to stop the knight from
jumping into C2 I guess you can play
Rook C1 but then I think Notre back
wants to push C6 and start you know
pushing White's Pieces away from their
dominant posts and Wesley a classy move
there Bishop back to A4 not fearing
Knight D3
I I fear 93 I just behalf exactly
wow get the king out of the out of the
line of fire of White's Bishop
was Knight T3 just like not a problem at
all I guess just rookie too
is there some like exchange sack oh yeah
yeah
I don't think uh I I don't think there's
enough there but
okay rookie two damn girl I think Rook
takes F3 Knight G5 deserves
consideration
was there any Merit to playing Bishop D3
just to force the Rook to go to D2 or is
white actually happy with the Rook on D2
anyway we're past that point well I
think white is well it might be relevant
because Rook takes F3 is still in the
equation
um in some of these positions I I tend
to agree with you though I don't think
black gets quite enough compensation
and Notre back wants to err on the side
of playing more solidly so maybe a move
like Queen F6 is what the doctor ordered
here
right exactly there's no need to play
Rook takes F3 if you're down three games
and it's bullet maybe you play Rook
takes F3 there you go Queen F6 so I
guess takes takes a knight H4 Knight F5
is an idea
but that Knight on D5 is a beast and
suddenly Levy we're kind of singing a
different tune Black's pieces are now
better plays than their counterparts how
did that happen it's it's weird because
White's pieces are all on the correct
squares maybe except the rook and E2 I
don't know what it's doing it should go
back to E1 ASAP but
the white pieces just don't
they don't do anything they're like on
the right squares they're not doing
anything the black pieces are all in the
wrong squares
but now with that they're all doing
something which does that even mean
they're on the right squares they're not
on the wrong squares anymore I don't
know man it's too early for riddles but
Wesley's trying to Wesley's trying to do
something with the pieces that are that
he's got right the the hand that he's
dealt he dealt with yourself I guess 94
is such an easy move to just kind of
glance over and say yeah he's attacking
the queen but it's so easy to go wrong
here with black queen F7 there was
Knight F3 to H4 and you cannot afford to
give away your light squared Bishop here
but wait a second we've got some
fireworks
Knight takes E3
oh was fe3 a possibility
wow rookie three just allows the bishop
on B6 to kind of stay strong but maybe
fe3 was too weakening I think he's
throwing all his eggs in the Knight H4
basket okay well never mind now that's a
big decision by Notre by giving up the
light squares that's a crazy decision oh
my gosh ah that was his idea using the
pressure on F2
Knight G5 Queen takes F2 is the idea
there
nice idea Bishop takes B7
I guess he just goes Rook B8 and then
takes on F3 and takes on D4 and he's
definitely solved all of his problems so
I guess Wesley had to play Rook takes E4
instead of Bishop takes ah
and to meet Knight G5 with
just Knight takes you five maybe and
just attack on the light squares faster
than black could attack on the dark
squares great point and you couldn't
have taken an F2 there because of the
check on H5
but in any case
yeah we're
we said that whole sequence without we
said that whole thing in our heads
without even like showing it to the
audience all right guys you
you had to be there guys sorry yeah that
joke sort of situation
yes uh this is a problem Wesley doesn't
like his position and this is Wesley's
look at the time
yeah this is what motorbike has to try
to do he's up two whole minutes on the
clock
that's 120 seconds
it is
foreign
60 seconds less than 180 seconds
I was trying to find something Snappy to
say but I couldn't figure out another
way to say like two minutes that's all
right that's all right it's all good
whoa uh
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa uh
uh
that's a crazy move man not just because
the eval bar plummeted he why'd he go
there and not the C2 well because he
wants the C2 Square for his Queen
Wesley's idea is to meet Knight F3 Rook
F3
Queen takes D4 with Queen C2 but
motorbeck strikes Aunty four immediately
and that's what Wesley missed what a
move
oh
am I allowed to say sexy
I just did you could you could say
whatever what do you think what are they
gonna do fire you do they know who you
are
come on come on nobody can do math as
fast as you Bishop takes D4 amazing move
amazing yeah wow
Daniel this is the this is the thing
when you spend like 50 to 60 percent of
your time on a move
it's gonna be a bad move it's just
somehow it's just what happens he
completely missed the forest for the
trees and uh
yeah I mean he just blunders the tactic
with F2 stuff now and noid your back is
right back in this match he most
certainly is I think he can just snap
off the pawn on B2 I I don't think he
should fear Queen C2 just really really
quickly for those uh watching at home
Knight takes D4 Queen takes F2 and black
picks up the rook and most importantly
if Queen takes D4 then black takes on F3
that's a check folks and the queen loses
its support motorbeck just goes A4
cold-blooded
and Wesley trying to muddy the waters as
much as he can
oh my God Levy a b h g and Bishop takes
F2 I think ends the game
oh
good bye I'll see you later
yep Queen takes B2 on the
nope not yet on the board there we go
there we go there yeah yeah nice okay
Queen A1 Queen D3 last ditch attempt by
Wesley
at the very least you could go G6 in
that position and drag the queen back to
G7
yes I I but I wonder if there's like
Rook takes F3 but no no that's it's not
you know it's not crazy oh dude can you
play like Queen A1 Queen B1 I'm thinking
about that and then b a
he's like winning for black it's got to
be winning for black
no he's not gonna do it he's gonna go G6
yeah G6 is smart Queen back to G7
you know what they say Queen on G7 never
mate or something like that that's
Knight on f8 never made Queen on G7
never made just go G6 no you're back
come on boss it's right there maybe G6
Knight H4 is giving him some fits
but I just Queen E5 Queen takes G5 once
the king gets G7 it's totally winning he
takes on F3 wow
well you might as well
you might as well he could just play G6
now or queen E5 and then G6 yeah because
Queen E5 F4 there's a check on E1 he
does go G6 this is still a bit scary
it's definitely a bit scary a little bit
yeah that's no but Queen E5 goodbye
Queen E5 and uh Queen takes G5 you know
you could do anything you want I guess
it's not totally over maybe maybe it's
it's good to just go Queen G7 and play
solid here
plus they will go F4 I think absolutely
and note about going for mate rookie
eight I think he wants
yeah he
sh oh Queen T4
King G8
oh there's no Bishop A2 I forgot B3
exactly
oops oops yeah this is
rookie eight and Indie Fortress okay
against Wesley it really sometimes feels
like it's never over
it it these guys they never die I think
Wesley should try Bishop takes G6 and
force Notre back to display the mate but
Queen E2 and rookie 3 is clinical it's
Surgical and he's got made into on H3
beautiful
and it's a tide match unbelievable
honestly norderbeck just made a
two-point comeback that was super
impressive right there
it was it was really impressive and it
might be too early to start calling
story lines but I I I gotta tell you
it's been a story of of two matches just
drastically so just right off the bat it
looked like 88 12 was generous to
noisybeck like after those first two
games it was like this is Wesley's just
gonna run him over uh but then Wesley
forced the draw
and then nordgerberg just played a
brilliant fourth game and I would even
argue that fifth game was equally if not
more impressive
no it was incredibly impressive he
exploited Wesley's blunder perfectly but
even more importantly that was some
super impressive opening preparation
King h8 and F5 an idea that I will admit
I was very skeptical about positionally
looks dubious but notabeck clearly
looked it up during the break he
consulted some of his opening files and
to go for that line against Wesley is
not easy and then to follow up as
accurately as he did
is equally impressive okay so we have a
fundamentally different path that
they're taking here with D4 on the board
early
what do you make of this yes let's com I
mean it's
totally totally different I mean Dojo
back has played King H1 G4 he's
definitely not going to be doing it this
time
uh we don't see any of the a5a4 stuff no
direct trying to prove a point in this
position down the middle
and
I don't know what's next for white like
what do you do you take on D6 and take
on E5 I never know what to do in these
types of positions
well in that case maybe we just don't
say anything and let them make a move I
think so I think the problem Levy if you
take on E5 is actually maybe F take C5
and black that's that f file pressure on
the other hand I agree that D6 becomes a
very tender spot that white can easily
attack
just basically says I've got a slightly
more pleasant position with no risk
there's no button number three
yeah
B3 I really like these positions for
white I don't like black snide on B6 but
I I don't play this with either Color
Wow wow
F5 both guys taking a picture at the
other's book playing yes five it's
amazing two can play at that game says
Wesley now the kind of obvious drawback
is that white has Knight G5 but I guess
then black can drag the queen up to F6
and protect the bishop
that's exactly right there are some
juicy scenarios that you want to avoid
if we could bring up an analysis board
after Knight G5 Bishop D7
would be an example of the kind of
nonchalant move that's very easy to fall
into and before you know it ab6 Queen C4
check and Knight F7 picks up the
exchange so
I think Knight G5 is a testing move but
black is probably spoiled for choice
between F6 yes and I think it's a little
a little too early in the match for some
catastrophic blunders to be made I think
they still have plenty of time to kind
of see through everything but
and you think it's possible of course
about it
yeah I I don't like
I said I suddenly take back what I said
F5 will make me question a lot of things
yeah it's a super complicated you know I
actually think white should probably
just go d-take C5 and just snap off a
pawn
that that is a free Pawn well free in
quotes
d e what is the idea exactly that's what
I can't put my finger on ah it's fe4
Queen D6 and maybe like
Queen E8
but then wait after defe you can't
really go Queen D6 though right because
then I can take and take the Knight on
F3
I forgot about that so yeah so f e d e f
Queen E4 Bishop D5 is probably just very
nice for Black 2 right yeah because then
you can snap that Knight off enough
three ruin White's King side structure
I'm not convinced that that resulting
position is as clear-cut as it may seem
because why does the Deep file why does
the bishop on an open board
but this is I think what Notre back is
calculating he's down two minutes on the
clock
and change
this is a huge time disparity wow
geez got to make a move Notre back and
he goes C4
what a cold move
well just
nothing is ever going to D5 in Black's
position now so ever yeah not in a
million years what do you do here with
like you play like f
f
f f f f f f something F you take any
four do you play F4
yeah it's hard to say because F4 Bishop
D2 and if you drop the anchor of the
pawn chain then that's gonna be a
problem Effie and Bishop F5 comes to
mind almost traps the queen
but the queen does have this H4 Square
which is protected by the Knight and in
that end game Levy I think black might
be slightly worse because of that pawn
on D6 being a major weakness you don't
want that if you're Wesley
well I would imagine
Wesley's like what was that Daniel
oh E4
okay versus a queen trade
he's just trying to he's trying to use
the momentum to sort of be like I'm not
where's blah blah blah blah blah I'm not
worse you know I got like my Pawn on e4
I'm gonna push my Palms forward I'm not
worse D5
but
I don't know if I believe it
I would have seriously contemplated just
C5 and B4 notarbeck kind of keeping the
tension I mean definitely white is not
risking I think white is ultra solid
here
but I don't see Wesley losing this
either he is ultra solid as well
which basically means straw
we got mvl in chat
hi Maxime
I you know uh Who's Your World Cup
favorite
who is my world cup favorite yeah for me
I like Croatia
what sorry Maxine
Croatia a bunch of old geezers bro
France is like a super fun team talented
fast
but you can root for more than one
people okay no you can't it's the World
Cup boss what do you mean you gotta root
for a garbage team like us and you gotta
root for a team that has a chance like
you know France unfortunately I was I
made these big plans to wake up and
watch TV in bed when the US was playing
um oh my gosh who did they lose to the
Netherlands and I woke up with seven
minutes left in the match so
you didn't have to wake up for that I
mean yeah can I just say something now
that I have like an audience by the way
Anish giri talking trash about the
Netherlands beating the United States is
the equivalent of making fun of a
six-year-old for getting beat up by an
eighth grader oh that's totally true
totally true I mean and I'm not I'm not
I'm sure renish has kicked or thrown a
ball in his life all right so who you
know what I'm saying you know what Anish
Anisha is so nice in person but so mean
online all right you just set up a
Twitter firestorm
he's
he's so nice I met him and we met him in
Toronto he's so nice why is he making
fun of you in the United States for
losing the Netherlands anyway here we
got United States versus Uzbekistan all
right we got another world cup matchup
here anyway no I just have to get that
off my chest I have to get that off my
chest
so mad anyway French team is great
Brazil's great Croatia is great
everybody's great Chad is great MBL is
great fantastic
not a niche though you gotta be mad you
got very upset
so in the meantime I think Notre back is
making some progress not on the clock
but on the board
he's massaging Wesley's kind of weak
Central Pawn complex
maybe CD Rook C1
okay
very tough to get back into this
commentary after my little rant but it's
all right we're gonna do our best
well they've got an opposite colored
Bishop end game I think
so any Merit here to the bishop being
better than the Knight like if you play
Knight takes D5 you know Bishop's better
than Knights I would be true I would be
scared of going for that actually
because then the Knight might land on E6
before you know it
here at least the white keeps a cushion
and Wesley had to prevent the move
Knight F5
I don't know I think this is heading for
a draw but given underbeck's clock
anything can happen
wait why did Wesley I thought B5 there
by black mate
but now he plays it yeah I don't know
Wesley's getting away from playing
Wesley moves Every Time I Think of a
Wesley move
he doesn't play it now
it's almost I would go so far as to say
he's beginning to outplay Notre back
from this end game
the logistical problem is that you can
never move the bishop because of rookie
five
yep
and of course Knight D7 fails the Knight
takes D5 and Knight B6
which is easy to miss by the way
I'm waiting for white to try to crack at
the center with F3 but it's just never
possible like like looking at different
ways Knight D1 Knight C3 rookie one F3
just go for it but
okay
six kind of a bunch of Pawn play now the
king side has dried up and white was
almost in zukespong
Shuffle King E6 King Des no no game's
still going Wesley's playing for a win
like without question at this point I I
think he's gonna go Rook A3 try to trade
a pair of Rooks
and Surround White's weak Queen side
Pawns
Knight A4 Maybe
yeah Wesley's gonna go to town here this
is exactly what he wants no risk
position better end game and he can make
a zillion improving moves when and if he
wants to make them
Oh What A Move
what a move he he just realizes that the
pawn is gonna die oh look at the
patience to go Knight B6 he's trying to
prevent White's Rook from infiltrating
Knight A4 I would take on B4 I think he
should take his chance here
yeah he's got he's gonna allow 95 and
Rook C7 but
such is life
yeah and then I would not play King E6
because of a rook C6 check maybe King E8
is actually the best way I know it's
passive but
that might be the most efficient move
that move looks impossible to play King
E8 well amazing move
just to avoid getting and he does it
but the bishop comes out to E5 white is
very active the issue is that the Rook
is going to move away and black is just
gonna
Dash the beep on forward but not like
that because now the pawn struggles to
move
yeah how are you gonna get it to B3
well I thought there might have been
some oh there you go that's how he's
doing now it's over at home Rook C1
yeah not your breakfast is not fast
enough he's behind by a move and King F6
there was a very important check on C6
first
to knock the king away
no joke I can't believe it I I'm not
sure we can fully believe it I mean
Wesley just totally outplayed him there
with black it was amazing and it wasn't
like there was an easily identifiable
blunder Notre bag was making normal
moves and in the blink of an eye he's
just lost
Knight F6 or H1 anything is winning
shouldn't have gotten paired against
Wesley you know no it is just a brutal
round of 16 matchup
and now just sit back and watch this
technique
I was gonna say brutal round of 16
speaking of we had mvl versus nepo and
that was round one like that's a final
in like 99 tournaments out of 100 and
that was a round one matchup
all right it's like Djokovic Nadal in
the round of 128 in Wimbledon or
whatever yeah they're just playing in
the qualifiers they just travel to the
event to get into the the tournament all
right the E4 E5 Master Class continues
this time we have Knight C3 we haven't
seen this yet normally you don't see
this ever really
but uh it's trendy now the Knight can go
to D5 or A4
super trendy you I mean and at some
point this was just delegated to
relegated to you know beginner games
basically this is what you play when
you're just learning chess right just
develop your pieces like that but now
all the top guys are doing it and Knight
D5 is one of the main ideas here for
white to put early pressure on black
Center
well not anymore I guess
oh okay another super early approach by
attacking in the center D4
I don't know about this though
okay neuterbeck just trades on D4 wait I
that I also don't really like now I feel
like White's clearly gonna have the edge
yeah uh
this just looks like a really bad
philador defense no
Rebecca's just
sex weaknesses and he's gonna to go
Bishop E6
and he's very very solid but this is not
what you want to have against Wesley
like the worst kind of position to have
against Wesley
does white go back to B3 here or just
white play rookie one
or rookie one maybe A4 just like play F4
Rook D3 and Rook G3 and Checkmate wow
if you gave me 10 moves I wouldn't have
played Bishop B2
yeah he's kind of leaving the bishop on
E6 in the dust I actually think he's
seriously flirting with the idea of f4
yeah
I think so too he's basically going to
argue that the bishop is bad on E6 and
it can be a target maybe even Bishop F3
after that you don't even have to attack
just
for sure
for sure but I think it all starts with
F4
there it is goes for it
no you're right Bishop F3 might be the
main idea here especially if Lex Bishop
reroutes to C6
which I think notrepec is likely to do
It's a combination of being attacked
uh
on the king side with also just space in
the center and the pressure on the queen
side kind of like being the the main
course of action even though it looks
like white should just Checkmate on the
king side A6 wow yeah you know notorbeck
kind of sleep walked into this position
that early trade on D4 kind of just
handed White
the long-term advantage and now Wesley
is just feels so comfortable here
but again he still needs to make
progress he's got the nice pawns the
nice pieces but where's the Breakthrough
going to be
foreign
yo I kind of want to play G5
like that's right
at some point I mean at some point it
might be a good idea because you
undermine the E5 square and then you can
play 97.95 and then just have the best
night of all time no that's a totally
legitimate idea and I've even seen it
when the king castles
I guess if you play G5 White's Gonna
Keep the tension with Queen E2 I know
you didn't say immediately
no I meant immediately I I just didn't
think Queen D2 I just thought I'll
figure it out G5 it's probably a
horrible move right now but
um but it probably loses Merit after C6
you can never play G5 now because now D6
will hang all the time so yeah
and that would involve bringing the
bishop back to C8 and then you'd have a
hard time going Knight D7
so Wesley continues to improve his
position but he's not really making any
concrete progress in the last couple of
moves Notre back on the other hand Levy
is perhaps preparing to start pushing
his own Queen side pawns and that can
get that could get very dicey for white
yeah it could
white did everything
Now sort of struggling to find to find
the next step of the position does white
play G4 ever G4 Rook G2
I would seriously consider it and at
that point you just have to start
calculating G4 B5
Rook G2 C5 Wesley making a very Wesley
move
he puts the king happy here he puts the
King on the same diagonal as the black
queen and the weak F4 Pawn it's just
insane I would never play that
wow here goes neuterbeck with this queen
Side Pawn so you might go A5 he might go
C5
he he might also just do nothing I mean
he could yeah
you could just say well if I need it if
I need it the threat is more valuable
than the execution right so if I need to
play A5 C5 and all this stuff I will but
yeah like Bishop C
8 you're exactly right it keeps this in
reserve you might be preparing C5 and
Bishop E7 exerting pressure on the E4
Pawn
fascinating the game just watching these
guys like a high level boxing match
speaking of three days some serious
people will be boxing
I will be pegged to the screen
by the way can I play G5 now
no bro no no no no what am I doing Queen
G3 and we want to see this move on the
board don't you it's I I really do but
no C5 he's he he's playing the right the
right way he's playing just the right
way the way it should be now
25 here at least has to be calculated E5
might be a way to liquidate and get a
relatively risk-free position for white
I feel like that's up Wesley's alley if
he can make it work calculationally
that's not a word
calculationally there's no way that
calculationally is come on I'm Googling
this here I actually got the browser you
can't get away with it I think it's one
of those things where it is going to be
a word like I think it's obscure but it
is a word
and by your silence I take it it is a
word oh my God that's not a word man by
means of calculation that's so
ridiculous that doesn't that sounds like
a made-up word
calculationally it does sound weird when
you say it a bunch of times I look I
look back at the screen it looks like
Black's position just scattered all over
the place D6 B4 oh my gosh
yeah calculationally I think black is
doing okay here
yeah my uh
my my instincts were incorrect there
just
yeah
see this is why
this is why I just your your subscriber
account on YouTube should count not your
sat number you know what I'm saying like
that that's just that's just my my
English sat section did not go well all
right
uh either did mine for that matter and
neither is Black's position after E5 I
think which Notre back might have just
allowed
oh Bishop F3 there's e takes F6 uh yeah
attack double attack indeed
wait what does Mike do
because you also wait can you take on E5
actually
holy smokes Rook d8 Queen d8 Bishop B7
there's e takes F4 Queen D3 though at
the end of that line
Queen D3
okay that's worth showing if we could
bring him an analysis board D takes C5
is what we're discussing
now we might still get this because the
line doesn't even end there e takes F4
looks like black wins but Queen G3 to D3
and apparently Levy I'm shocked that the
evil bar isn't
reflecting the fact that white is up a
piece you want to know why this is a
queen B8 Queen C7 19
oh my God and the idea is to deflect the
White Knight off of F2 so that you can
take the queen and take the rook and if
HG and black has this Vision so Queen H4
Holy Cannoli that's that's gross just
absurd Knight f60 G4 only move that
doesn't lose
wow well if you follow the philosophy of
always look for checks it's the only
check so maybe he will find it but he
only has 40 seconds
and uh unbelievable let me say something
right now you do not feel good seeing E5
on the board
no and if you don't play D takes E5 if
you can't make that work
then your position is just starting to
crumble F5 Bishop G4 lots of attacking
moves and he goes for it did he see
Knight G4
I think I mean you have to write if you
go through the sequence of moves
or did he miss queen D3
that's the big question now it could be
both
he could have missed Queen D3 but with
20 seconds is he gonna see Knight G4 in
time
it's a beautiful move oh my gosh I don't
think he sees it
but you never know it's it's noted like
he missed it I missed Knight G4
how could he miss this obvious move ah
but oh he he yeah I guess he just missed
the sequence of moves where all the
pieces are defended oh no
Queen F3 is a pivotal move without that
move black would have won the piece back
and now it's over black white is just up
a full Miner
Knight D3
whatever you want to do here is winning
yeah two two seconds on the clock and
there's just nothing King is just too
weak
eat was there no there wasn't
just Queen C8 go for mate Queen F7 this
one Queen and Bishop versus queen is a
draw but bishop and four pawns like
Queen D5 probably just wins for white or
or queen G8 check I thought he should
have played first oh yeah he he missed
that he completely missed that but what
is black even threatening I guess he
wants A4 nah come on
come on
there's nothing here yeah
checking that there's no mate but
you can just play Queen G6 and maybe
even H4
I wonder if Wesley's kind of milking the
clock a little bit he's just enjoying
himself the results of the game is not
in question and I mean that's a great
feeling when you know you're gonna win
you just have zero doubts and you're
just kind of enjoying yourself yeah he's
gonna take on maybe yeah he's gonna give
another check
and uh
story of winning streaks two for Wesley
two for know your back now two for
Wesley again and this will be the final
game in all likelihood of this segment
given how prolonged the games have been
very much so
and this is a pivotal game for Notre
back I mean can he do what he just did
the first time can he curb the lead
with a win Wesley jumps out to a
three-point lead
and I actually think the change in time
control favors him I mean Wesleyan three
plus one is just
a force to be reckoned with
by the way this time the bishop went out
to G5 and H4 which is a line that's
extremely provocative
whoa
is that normally what they do I think so
and it's actually the reason why black
doesn't Rush with the move D6 I think
that's how it was taught to me at least
so interesting
I guess the role of Tempe is diminished
in a position like this because of how
solid black is he can afford to make two
moves with the same piece yeah I just
thought that they played Bishop C5 and
then play like G5 and
again we're sort of in the spot where
I mean it's different to be down four
and a half to two and a half versus two
and a half to half or two zero like when
you just need to get on the board
um yeah no deer breaks got to relax here
for a second this is another game like
three games in a row that they're just
trying to blow up the center with an
early D4
exactly
now Bishop takes C6 and D takes E5 black
of course will take the pawn on e4
I I have a feeling that Wesley is still
in his analysis here somehow
judging from his absolutely
lackadaisical approach and just
various behaviors I would say and that's
quite yeah it's quite likely
um you know what what a obscure pet
peeve in mine is sorry to cut you off I
actually want to compliment you you said
correctly lackadaisical most people say
lackadaisical which is actually wrong
there's no s there
do people say that I would just slap
them
I regularly slap them but they're pretty
lackadaisical in their in their
pronunciation well I could see the
headline already and you know serial
slapper goes around Charlotte just
hitting people for mispronouncing words
exactly um serial slapper
ah I mean all right another trade on D4
we have the identical structure to the
previous game how do you like that
uh I uh I'm confused why
we are repeating it but
such is life I mean
seems like we'll be seeing e45 quite a
lot
and I'm uh I'm all for it
now the bishop has a big decision as to
where it goes back in order back taking
the conservative approach just making
sure E4 is over protected
but I think Wesley's fine here in the
end game
a little boring A4
all right hey there G5 Knight H5 just go
for the bishop pair
I would go for the bishop pair
I don't see what's wrong with it
yeah I mean Bishop on F6
yeah but it's traditionally there's a
queen on D1 so this is not possible
but uh Queens are gone
I know the eval bar doesn't reflect this
but I actually think notrex A4 move was
really careless I think this gives
Wesley
kind of carte blanche in a position like
this two Bishops
a bishop on F6 pressuring B2
white definitely needs to be on the
careful side here
uh Bishop to E6 now
and uh
I don't know I
maybe Wesley's just not rushing taking
on G3 he's not exactly sure
because white can play like HG
maybe F4 and uh
I mean at this rate there's a chance
this game isn't the last game they might
just swap off some pieces and no they
totally might there might be some
liquidation here
after Bishop F6 I agree Knight takes C6
and C3 now there's still some meat on
the bone and norterbeck actually
refrains from taking on E6 he likes his
Knight
tonight
interesting question after Bishop takes
D4 the light squared bishop and Rook end
game for for whoms was that better
for who's the one uncorking the SAT
words today
uh I don't know but I really want to
play Rook A5
it's just like
looks so stupid rookie five Knight B3 I
guess probably oh and then Rook takes D6
working the Bishops I can't do that just
yet I really wanted to play Rook A5
so he goes Rook Ada to make sure that
the pawn on D6 is going to be protected
in the event that the light Square
Bishop moves and now the position's
starting to spice up a little bit
yeah there's a four
as expected
yeah kind of a cat and mouse game
neither side really willing to take too
many risks
but one gets the sense that eventually
the center is likely to just blast open
but how
this is the question yeah
well Black's not gonna go C5 I would
imagine although that's not out of the
question C5 and Bishop C6 at some point
of course that gives up the the B5
Square
oh Bishop G4
interesting move preventing Rook F to D1
what about Bishop
d
one dude and I want to try to get my
knight to F5 I was thinking that too
maybe he was worried the E4 Pawn would
be weak at the end of the line he
doubles on the f file the first threat
of the game Levy F takes G5 I feel like
this is the first thing blackouts had to
address all game long and in shocking
fashion Wesley sees the one move thread
and has parried it
crazy to think about that you know
Bishop D1 there's uh there could be some
Bishop takes D4
and like all of a sudden black is uh
just gonna trade off the pieces into a
better rook and game I'm not saying
right now but yeah because E4 is such a
problem for white in this position
huh
so how is Notre Bay going to continue
improving he's made all of the obvious
moves is he just gonna tread water and
go back to D2 basically offer a draw
I think he is and he does
yeah rookie too
we might get a we might get a game what
game seven eight
yeah I think I I think um
it is likely and it depends on Wesley's
mindset Wesley probably does have a way
to mix things up here but with a
two-point lead in the black pieces I
think he'd be happy to get another game
in
wait that would be nine games this is
game eight right I can't I I can't add
they've played seven games they played
seven games yeah four and a half two and
a half does add up to seven I believe
yeah I was like four and a half my brain
did some while so that was like four and
a half plus two and a half that's seven
so they've played six games and that
would mean that the next game would be
it was like
six six six that was cool that was cool
it was good that's why I'm commentating
and you know
I believe we'll leave the mathematical
calculations to the uh I gotta I got a
statistics degree we don't know how to
do arithmetic we just T values and all
this garbage
statistically significant and all this
stuff oh my God that brings back
memories and The Rook once again moves
into D1
Bishop back to E7 I suppose
oh
finally wait E5 and F5 doesn't that win
a piece yeah I was gonna say E5 F5 what
oh there's Bishop C5 check oh but I mean
it's still
B4 can you play B4 here with white and
just play F5 next
he plays F5 immediately Wesley's gonna
drop back to C8 and try to surround
these two pawns no but they're
definitely more of a strength and a
weakness yeah no this is not good this
is there's no way
what do you think about like King H2 G4
King G3 something like that I'm trying
to figure out like where does White's
King want to go
I think G3 is a solid Square you got to
be a little careful about like Bishop E3
Bishop F4 there
yeah I would also consider the move B4
to chase the black Bishop back to f8 yes
yes very much so what wow wow is he
actually gonna follow up with King G3
wait but H5 is a free Pawn right can you
play F6 here and force the black king
like to move H6
that's a double-edged sword though you
could end up losing a bunch of your
Pawns in the center oh my god there was
like some insane line okay um we can't
look at it was it with Bishop E3 Bishop
F4
no it was like uh King G3 like forced
like F6 King H6 King G3 H4 and then you
can play like Knight H4 takes takes G5
mate oh my God that that actually was a
beautiful detail maybe we can show that
after the game
but for now we've got a lot more action
here Bishop D6 check I think black is in
trouble after King H3 because this is
this is nuts you're not getting to the
king if it sits on G4 because the Knight
protects the H4 Square there is no fear
to be had here for white
the Vikings on H3 like come and get me
bro do something the bishop on C8 Bishop
on C8 is Never Gonna Move by the way
ever like b5a5 or B5 ab5 and black loses
uh it's just never gonna move which is
ultimately killer this is probably gonna
be the last game of the five minute
segment I don't see Wesley losing this
in the next 30 seconds
correct uh yes yeah meaning he would
lose fast enough for there to be a
for there to be enough time to start
another game and we have another
situation like right before the last
break not your back pressing pressing
pressing
he's got to win this one yeah this is
very reminiscent of that game where he
brought his King all the way around and
look at the pressure that he's applying
on the queen side he's gotten his Pawn
to B5 he's trying to provoke C5 Levy
then the Knight will come back and you
will lose the D5 pawn and kind of
without the game
absolutely black has nothing which is
literally nothing he has to block his
own Bishops those are the saddest
Bishops ever really are Rook Bishop's on
C7 and C8 and Notre back just keeps
dialing up the pressure finding ways
to tighten the screws and if Wesley ever
puts the Rooks on the D file white plays
Rook H1 black resigns immediately and
look at this he's going to season yep
he's seizing control of the H file and
he's C5 can you play Rook H2
I think that might have been possible he
takes the more straightforward approach
Wesley driving his Pawn down to C4 but
now look at that D4 Square oh my God I
think Rook H2 is that was incredible it
was definitely winning yeah I agree no I
think that was the way but now you've
taken go Bishop E4 it's over for you
that's it wow that's game Bishop takes
D5 Bishop takes C4 bang bang Bishop B7
oh that would have been cool
uh okay Rook H2 there it is infiltration
second
he's E I thought there was E7 but okay
I thought Bishop takes C6 and F5 maybe
can you go like to stay in the game
night night detail I really want to go
Knight D2 but uh uh uh Bishop's alive
wait a minute that was premature and
he's got one second oh he blunders A4
there should be eight somehow I don't
know oh my God the King has almost made
it and now he's gonna win E7 oh Knight
G5 Knight G5
wait why couldn't he have taken because
of F6 or H2 Rook H2 oh no
is Wesley Gonna Save this King takes F5
as possible Bishop a uh oh he's gonna
take on F6 and no Direct's gonna go King
F7
what is happening
why you pretty much
increment Wesley
what was that oh my God what did we just
see noise your back waves off the game
as if that was the worst thing I've just
ever done in my life but he gets the win
that is so important why did Wesley
pretty move Bishop takes C8 he had 2.4
seconds which in the context of a Time
scramble is kind of an eternity that was
just a total mental lapse
and oh my goodness what a comeback
effort by Wesley but it's just not quite
enough Levy what did we just see I feel
like we were just literally spouting out
moves that they were not playing also
our moves were wrong like it just that
was completely nuts so up and down
roller coaster for the last 10 or 15
moves of that game I feel like twice now
we've seen games like that where noser
bag just hangs on for dear life and he's
gotten two out of two so credit to him
in those games
and that's how he needs to try to play
needs to try to steer these games into
time scrambles relatively speaking
that's still the area that Wesley finds
himself least comfortable in but the
score is three and a half four and a
half the five minute segment is
concluded folks and before we go on a
short break and start out our 60 Minutes
of three plus one a reminder that
registration is open for the spring 2023
season of the Collegiate chest league if
you are a university student and want to
represent your school in the best online
chess league for college students sign
up now do not miss your shot they make
history in the biggest CCL season to
date Type X Glam CCL X Glam CCL in the
chat for more registration closes on
January 13th so don't procrastinate
ladies and gentlemen we are in for yet
another barn burner the match between
Wesley and noterbeck is heating up and
we'll be back with 60 Minutes of three
plus one action on the other side of
this short break
thank you
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or in
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm oh
we missed it oh
my goodness the wheels the wheels have
come out that could be the magic for
some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness 98 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabby it exhausting every last
resource the battles will be electricity
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship Jam Daniel nerdinski I am
Levy Rosman chopping it up for you today
we've got a lovely double header this is
the first match between Wesley so and
notrebek abdusator of 90 minutes of the
match have passed and Levy it has been
back and forth back and forth Wesley
currently leads by a point
we could not ask for more entertainment
in these 90 minutes no we couldn't have
and we've had so many plot twists and
momentum shifts and sporadic uh bursts
of genius and Madness
and it's everything you can ask for when
you get two very very high quality
players uh I don't believe that the
anticipated score line according to the
statistics was a one game match but as a
spectator as a commentator you can't ask
for much more
and nothing brings me more satisfaction
than to say smarter chess was wrong so
Wesley definitely with the upper hand in
the majority of the match but Notre back
had his incredible moments including
that last game or quarterback somehow
pulled out the win due to a bad pre-move
let's take a look at their chess.com
Blitz insights before we jump into the
three plus one of course the thing that
jumps out at me Levy is Wesley's average
accuracy he is known even among super
GMS as essentially a machine and you can
see that reflected here 89 is pretty
wild especially over 1800 games you
could argue that nojebec has obviously
played more uh and therefore his
accuracy is lower you could also make
the case know your back was a young guy
on this account right like he's played
maybe games on this account when he was
not as good as he currently is so uh
there's a lot of different ways you can
play around with numbers and um you know
what they say
uh five out of every four statistics
uh statistical points might be might be
incorrect anyway so uh I like to see
that nodier Beck uh is taking the fight
to Wesley in this match in a variety of
different ways and he has taken
advantage of some of Wesley's mistakes
and those could be in time scrambles as
we just saw those could be just over
optimistic play that's sort of what I
would say like Wesley hasn't been blown
off the board in too many games he's got
a little over optimistic especially last
game and uh lack of caution caused them
uh to get overwhelmed by nozier back so
what do you think is going to happen as
we remove two minutes of clock time whoa
from the players uh wise Quest this time
at 2 40.
is he playing a bomb cloud
is he channeling I'm just up dude he's
literally spent 20 seconds on the first
move and he was at his desk I think he
was like flat out deciding what to play
really wow so Wesley just
that's so interesting because you would
think that is the happier of the two
right
no you totally
I'm just can't get over the fact that he
played One E3 I think that's the first
time Wesley's ever made that move
yo can you very quickly just go back
before no job's last move
um I I don't I don't know if we can or
we're just following the game wasn't
this the game on Drake and Wesley and
like they played a game uh in this in
the G in the cgc finals and I'm pretty
sure Wesley took on D4 and just got a
really good Carrow with black no I agree
and this time motorbike allows white to
take on C5 and get kind of a really good
Queen's gamut accepted
I'm so perplexed what is happening
I feel like Wesley's slightly better
here alrighty
I don't think nojerbeck was expecting E3
something tells me he wasn't now E3 C5
is kind of an interesting response the
move that I've kind of informally played
is just E3 E5
and go for a reverse exchange French
uh-huh
uh-huh e35
but interesting I kind of get his choice
but then C4 then C4 and you have some
English and exactly
and you have to be okay playing that
English you know if that's not your
repertoire you don't want a fortnight's
English then
good luck
yeah I mean of course the king's Indian
setup is also very good against D3
anyways here we have kind of a queen's
gamut accepted structure no question
that white has a pull why does the
better place Bishops these Bishops are
incredibly imposing but look at Notre
back B5 and Levy I think he wants to
follow up with a well-timed A5 and just
liquidate the queen side and make a draw
I mean what more can you ask for a
completely effortless draw in a
like 15 20 moves with black I'm sorry I
just toggled to Twitter real quick and I
I I uh chess was trending for a second
it said chess 14 000 tweets was like wow
and then I yeah you ever do that you
ever click something trending on Twitter
and it's just like you just have no idea
why it's trending that's sort of what
happened by the way Bishop takes F3 oh
my
forcing white to take back with a pawn
otherwise it would drop the bishop on D3
and no direct is the draw in his pocket
but Bishop takes before okay Bishop
takes B5 and sign peace treaty
uh this was a weird game man this was a
I don't know what happened here just
like a
like a Passback game basically I'm not
sure Wesley's gonna play this again
no something tells me he's gonna switch
back to E4 now this game isn't entirely
over Rook A5 that might be the clinical
way to do it skewering the Bishops and
forcing Bishop takes F6 now it's over
and I think withdraw for his forthcoming
do you play Bishop F6 Rook B5 or do you
play Bishop F6 gf6 yeah that's the
million dollar question I was hoping you
wouldn't ask me that
well there's our answer
riveting end game
yes absolutely riveting uh
wow
what an odd game
yeah I felt like Wesley was slightly
better out of the opening maybe he had a
better chance but
he never really got his foot onto the
gas pedal whoa a petroff
okay
it was a there was a trend like a few
years back on the internet and ever it
was kept going viral like uh
stop it was a vulgar word as I can't say
but it was like stuff blank says do you
remember that
like there was like uh no you don't
remember that Chit Chat am I going crazy
you guys remember that there was like
viral videos that were coming out like
stuff chess commentators thing like
things chess players say things uh I
understand it vaguely like I've seen
those types of memes
yeah well I was gonna say I feel like
chess commentary or you know things
super GM saying whoa Petra oh yeah
we had a our first opening change in an
hour and a half and this they're
following the game Levy nihal sarin
against or Wesley so against the hall
star and from game one of their cgc
finals they had this position on the
board
yes
and uh so did Wesley and uh Neiman right
so did Wesley and Neiman yeah good one
that was
that was the game uh like nehal and gear
and giri followed their game I don't
remember exactly how it went because
that's that's how it works but I think
it was Bishop of 49 C7
and then at some point he all played F6
yes but nihal played it slightly
incorrectly if I think
I'm pretty sure they're still following
the games there's a bunch of games in
the database Knight F5 has been played
here that seems to be an interesting
attempt rookie two is the kind of
conventional method you just double on
the only open file
oh no B3 that's what Wesley played so
notrebec is playing what Wesley did
against nihal the callers are reversed
yeah and then I was it Bishop E5
no Bishop D2 back okay
okay I think Bishop E5 was the move in
that game
I also think in any case
but all the pieces are so clustered
together
yeah and he goes rookie too
preparing to double on the e-file it
always seems to me like black is a
little bit uncomfortable in these
positions I don't know it just it just
feels like black doesn't quite have the
mobility Levy and the Knight can jump
into E5 at a moment's notice white has
C4 in a Blitz game I'm not sure about
this Choice from a practical standpoint
I completely agree with you
that I mean
to die it's uh it doesn't matter why why
uh White always seems to have the
pressure here bullet Blitz rapid
classical
but
these guys have a way of also making it
not really matter like I my
understanding of this position is
uh very limited but I I can say like oh
maybe Knight G7 Knight F5 looks good but
it's like completely not the right idea
I mean maybe you gotta do something
completely different
um I would much prefer to have white
here
no totally and I think Wesley might just
be going Bishop G7 Queen C7 and if he
can get all of the Rooks off the board
then he draws but give yourself a little
more Knight G7 on the board
what was that about it being the wrong
idea uh I never know if I should be
happy or if uh the player playing my
suggestion should be you know unhappy
um but yeah I I but dude I mean I think
you and I are on the same page about
this this looks so much easier to play
with white it totally is although Wesley
has done a great job of keeping a Time
Advantage now Knight takes F7 does not
work black recaptures with the Knight
and the other Knight defends The Rook
but Notre back continuing to massage the
weaknesses in Black's position I like
the move Queen F3
yeah maybe H4 and Knight E4 should be
considered or does black bite off more
than he can show
does that work well
he chooses rookie six God Knight F7
almost works
yeah it's like a miracle it doesn't uh
trying to play like Bishop H6 trying to
play like
yeah you want one of those moves I like
Bishop H6
let's try to play it
put some pressure
is there an idea there is there a knight
F1 and G4 stuff and then just come back
to G3
yeah I think that's one of his ideas and
he's just making some Loft but look at
Wesley just playing confidently playing
quickly and motorbikes got to watch his
clock here oh Knight D3 I was thinking
Bishop C1 Bishop A3 but it's a lot
easier to move other people's pieces
I did not know what to uh
it almost still feels a little bit
uncomfortable for black like White's
pieces are just a little bit more
compact in the center
and black is this weird Knight on G7 and
the bishop on F6 is loose Knight C5 wow
totally switching up the uh
the pace here we're going to the queen
side now Bishop G5 I feel like I just
like there's two guys playing a high
level game and I have no clue what's
going on I just
yeah it's the individual moves can be
hard to understand I think Bishop takes
G5 there's a trap he's gonna go Knight
takes G5 winning on the spot
that was a vicious idea by Wesley
and now I think he can take and go Queen
F6 if he wants to make a draw
what he might actually want more than
that
yeah Knight F1 back is Wesley
overextending or is he doing the right
thing though
it's hard to say because the drawback of
H4 I think this is what you're implying
is that you're giving the G4 Square for
White Knight
looks like they're just gonna draw this
one as well
but black is way more active here
yeah maybe it's worth trying something
like 94 going after the C3 Pawn
whoa
sax H4 he says come take me
I I feel like I haven't understood a
single move of this game yes C4 and now
if anybody's playing for anything I feel
like White's playing for something now
no don't hang it forward
do not hang a fork Wesley gives up H4
wait a second Knight G4 is a very nasty
idea here
although maybe it doesn't threaten
anything
okay Queen d8
um Queen a F
5 92 he moves his King away I hate them
I hated that move
I hate it but oh
oh it was the night end game just
winning I think black's just creating a
passer I think White's way too slow he's
gotta go C5
no that's not gonna cut it Knight D5 I
mean cd5 looks very natural and B5 and
A4 now white wants to stop the pawn from
C2
be for first and then A4 on the next
move oh wow does that work I don't know
I don't know if it does
oh I think motorbike's close to saving
this oh he had to play Knight B1
oh cause now he's gonna go B2 he has to
play Knight B1 yeah wait call
and now it's just winning B1 queen and
the Knight escapes via A3 no trip I
can't believe it he just allowed the
Knight to go back to C3 now he's just
losing oh my gosh
still a little bit of accuracy required
by Wesley
not totally over but okay now it is now
he's in zugsvong
wait what
oh
he had to play H6 before the king got
back to G7 I think
Wesley's choosing a super convoluted
method I would just go around to H6
and then sack on F5 yes yeah yeah there
it is beautiful
oh my God
that was a hard game to compensate
yeah that was a
that was a weird game
it's the three the whole Blitz section's
been a bit strange all right now it has
we have a sicilian and a sideline like a
king's Indian attack Style
reverse grun-filled kind of a thing I
don't even know what is going on here
this guy's a grunfeld structure wait
wait the move here is Wesley recommends
this in his course Queen E1 is very
dangerous for black
or at least I think it is
I'm captivated by this game I gotta
drink my apple mango a little yogurt
here
I don't know about what Wesley's doing
it's hard to say if he's still in his
preparation now from a positional
standpoint the night on D4 is obviously
a very strong piece but black has a lot
of activity in his own right rookie
eight Bishop H3 can create light Square
weaknesses on the king side
at least visually looks like black is
doing totally fine here
yeah black is great everything is
developed H3 is a very funny move
that is spicy and if you take on H3 you
lose the bishop on E7 and at the end
after an ig4 white is Queen H4
yes and there is no checkmate
very sad way to go out
uh that means you have to move your
Bishop
I actually like White's position quite a
bit I mean what happens if you play C3
uh and then just build around the
isolated Pawn also can't white play like
thinking like F4 G4 F5 but he doesn't
have to do any of that
the guy that has to win
yeah notrebrecht has to create counter
play down the E file he has to play a
well-timed knight E4 maybe even now
he drops his Bishop back to G6 first
solidifying his control of the E4 square
but I agree this is once again up
Wesley's alley he's gotten the kind of
position he wants
rookie one
okay Bishop before
what do you think about F3 here with
white is that moving sick
and the timing of that was absolutely
impeccable
thanks Wesley there you go
remember
in the cgc when I would call you Wesley
like on the regular
I know I
I mean thank you you know what I mean I
do
I was uh I mean that was very very nice
of you
I couldn't help it it was just it was
natural
um
I the more time that goes by the more I
begin to
more and more uh kind of my confidence
in White's position here is growing uh I
really like the trading of the pieces
and maybe rookie one at some point and
D5 is going to be under pressure but I
could be severely overestimating White's
position
and stockfish is sitting there like
you're very stupid but I I really like
it I mean Bishop F2 and just okay rookie
one chill
but a point you made earlier is that the
computer doesn't incorporate the trend
of the game who is who has who have the
last five ten moves favored who's the
one making progress
and that in many cases especially in a
Blitz game is just as important as who
is better right now in isolation and
it's clear to me that white is the one
the trend of the game definitely fares
white but can Wesley actually convert
something specific out of this beautiful
Knight on D4 and he's bringing it to F4
interesting idea it's amazing that his
King is going to be the one taking back
on F2 and yet it's completely fine
yeah because of that pawn on F3
holding down Black's minor pieces
and then the White's Bishop will come
around or even H4 Bishop H3
I'll I'll love this this is like
Wesley's in his element right now he
could he could just waterfall here in
the three plus one segment
no you just get that sense he's in Buzz
saw mode and Black's clock continues to
dwindle
Notre back down to 56 seconds
and there goes the centralization of the
queen
this is a completely worse nightmare
position to have against Wesley so like
it's it does not get any worse than this
although I love the move Bishop C2 it's
so nice doing a good job thus far
is the bishop going to E6
I think you might have to I think the
more immediate question is is the Knight
going to f4s or is Wesley going to delay
that move because he doesn't want to
trade heavy pieces
okay Bishop D7
I saw myself
was it just very slowly methodically
improving his position
it's constant honestly mesmerizing to
watch how he does it Bishop F1 there it
is yep very well timed Bishop one yep
prevents Rook C4 we were always gonna
that move was always happening just
decides he just decides to play it at
the exact right moment Chief exactly
G4 at some point for yg425 you gotta
watch out for Knight to E4 check
intercepting the queen but definitely an
idea that's on the horizon 29 seconds
now for Notre back
the Evo bar hasn't changed at all but it
feels like the position continues to get
worse for black
it just feels that way
yes of course yeah at some point he's
just gonna crack I mean
there's only so much of this you can
take
rookie five is possible but not that
effective he goes back to D1 yeah Wesley
loves just these kind of like easy moves
he just it's not gonna do anything just
I would consider C4
if I'm black I'm going to consider to
improve
it's just wow if you're black you would
consider what
I was going to say G5 but not anymore I
love that move I love it but I it's now
it's fatal
what a4a5 by white
A3 video
Bishop A2 he wants I think wow wow and
C4 now is now the time
no it still continues to improve no he's
gonna make nose your back get down to
like seven seconds or six seconds and
then he's gonna
wow completely opposite side of the
board
he wants G5 and the reason he put his
King on G2 is to prevent various
Shenanigans connected with Queen H2
check
this is like machine-like Precision from
Wesley
positions just completely under control
there's just no
there's nothing you can do
Black's position continues to
deteriorate but Wesley's clock is now
down to 20 seconds this is Notre back's
best chance get this into a Time
scramble and try to make it tactical at
the right moment
C4 there it is
oh my God take on D5
and then G5 cdg5 C5 is possible I was
gonna say yeah I like that
oh that's a nice move Bishop takes
the Knight stays on F4 to protect the E2
square but notrebrecht has gotten active
at the right moment yeah Wesley down to
six seconds this is scary stuff
Bishop C6 is a nasty nasty idea
targeting F3 yeah
Queen E2 Force the queen trade horse the
queen trade
oh no here's the movie oh
it felt like he had zero seconds he's
lagging
oh my gosh no no he's gonna flag
oh my god he has .5 seconds he's
flagging
wait what is going on
his internet gave out
oh no
he just lost on time
he lost on time it's just a clearly
better end game and not just after a a
surgical effort for the entire game to
get the pawn up on GameCube Flags
I feel like he flagged like four times
by the way I don't know is that even
possible
yeah he had zero seconds for like the
last five moves like
oh he's got a cat he knows the thing or
two about having nine lives right this
is just yeah that was wild
and it's not the first time and far from
the only time that Wesley said internet
problems affecting his match
it happened against Hikaru I think a
couple of months ago it's happened in
previous SEC matches and the closer you
get down to the bullet Lobby the more
this costume this is a heartbreaker you
don't even make a draw how does Wesley
not have like one gigabyte internet as a
taxable I don't get it we gotta set him
up with that we gotta set all these guys
if we do
wow I don't know what the situation is
in Minnesota with you know a t Fiverr
but if he needs an internet consultant
you know a t I'm offering my services
Google I mean Verizon
anything fiber optics
I watched my internet go down as I'm
talking about this no no no one that's
it's good
um that was tragic wow that almost that
could have been a three-game lead and
now everything is down to one game once
again
yeah that's a huge swing and another
Petrov
another pet shop they're repeating the
same exact line from the previous game
yeah fascinating that they that they go
for this uh
exact thing a second time
okay ig3 again I've kind of lost track
of what they had the first time because
all of these positions kind of look
identical to me
yeah the Knight is not on A6 yet the
bishop trade hasn't occurred yet
why is Wesley thinking
he's also got one bar of connection
which really worries me
oh I didn't even see that I've we uh we
connect to this big you know screen here
and I just have it open here I didn't
even realize that he has one bar of
connection that's not good
it's up to two bars but
it's less than four that's double
okay rookie eight so he's making all of
the same moves the Knight dropping back
to C7 and then moving into E6
in order to plug the e-file
but this is a good choice for notorbeck
relatively risk-free position and I
stand by what I said earlier I would
never play this with black personally
I would never feel comfortable to play
this what about for a hundred gifted
Subs
[Music]
attempt my uh you know
you know how to appeal the right how to
press the right buttons not not in
classical though you know maybe in some
Blitz Games but yeah it's yeah classical
a thousand Subs wouldn't make me go for
this
and Wesley uh Wesley performing
construction there on his house I uh
trying to figure out how to
I feel like we've seen so many
backgrounds in this match too and he's
like looked backwards and
oh
maybe there's a router behind him like
maybe his internet router's behind him
that's what he's been poking at by the
way doesn't Wesley usually play from
that desktop with like the tiny window
in the bottom right hand side like he he
plays yeah that was one of the which is
on a chair like that was a crazy photo
that we just played a couple of months
ago there of Wesley's setup it does feel
like he plays from a different location
every time
and it almost feels
you know the scary thing when you've got
about internet is then you never know if
he's actually thinking or if his
internet is down
there he goes again
oh
yeah this is
just casually beating knows your back
six games out of uh out of 11 well
constantly being distracted by other
things in this house
but once again I think this works out
for black because if white goes 95
Black's gonna go I think Knight F4 and
force Notre back to give away this
relatively important Bishop
and I guess not
yeah and nunchier back is happy to enter
the same lines even if he loses games
because he's getting good positions he's
not really losing the games because the
positions are bad
he is although we often talk about this
in the SEC context when you keep
repeating the same lines you get more
and more frustrated because you feel
like you should be better but if you're
not actually performing on result wise
it affects you psychologically
all right Knight D7
it's tempting but Queen H4 I think is
just fine for black
right
nobody's gonna go Queen G7 H6
okay we do have Knight D7
I mean the bishop has been seized
we have seized the bishop so do you want
to play H6 here with white or what do
you want to do yeah H6 just looks good
Bishop F4 looks like one of those moves
just to tighten the screws a little bit
and okay Notre back takes the more
ambitious approach C4
a trade on E2
okay 96 I think black is still fine
I'm I'm not sure that no jerbeck is
going to repeat this line
yeah that's the thing Wesley's just
neutralizing him here
I can't help but feel like white has not
gotten enough
and at this point is it a dead draw I
wouldn't say it's a dead draw maybe it's
worth going H6 and creating the
preconditions for a back rank mate
yes G4 also
very ambitious I like G4
Queen H4 is an interesting tactic here
trying to use tactics to solve the
problems but then white goes Queenie too
no that was unpleasant
the Knight is going to live on a uh E6
forever
yeah and motorbike just kind of bails
out I think this is tant him out to a
draw for
I feel like after a very bloody five
plus one it's been a very like relaxed
three plus one I just I can't extremely
you know what I mean I don't know what
it is I don't know what happened just
sort of
yeah the games have been super long
they've been kind of grinded out Affairs
and it almost feels like neither side
has had a big advantage in any of these
games
yeah despite multiple decisive results
we've just had like some movies exactly
okay maybe something something might
happen here I don't know meat on the
bone
G5 Knight F4
oh then Queen F4
okay now they're back just trades
it's still not totally over white can
pretend that he's slightly better after
Queen F4
but black takes and goes King F6
nice queen of four action then
all right losing this would take a lot
of effort so
maybe somebody wipes this can just
toggle between F4 and G4
and a draw for is forthcoming
riveting position riveting
tremendous game here by the by the boys
uh oh F5
F5 was tricky
no A6 A6
yeah black is okay
black is okay F6 locks up the position
and leads to a forced drop yeah another
one of those very kind of tame games and
you're right I think Notre back is going
to mix things up a little bit in the
opening uh in his next couple of white
games
okay so now we see
Wesley goes back to the to the E4
and noji back is completely fine
repeating this sort of
I don't know what you would even call
this
yeah the weird iqp structure but the
ball is a notorbeck's court
wait I'm super he's doing the exact same
thing literally and as position yeah
his position was terrible last time no
I'm
totally puzzled I feel like he might
have a an improvement in his mind that
he wants to try he didn't let Wesley go
H3
Aha and you're saying that was very
important because that preserved to the
bishop on G2 which is a key cog in the
machine yeah last time he got hit with
this H3 move and so E7 was loose but now
he actually gets to trade it and okay I
mean the light squares for white are
still going to be kind of weak but what
exactly is the point what if white just
plays
moves the queen and plays F3 C3 Bishop
F2 and does the exact same thing
I'm totally bemused white is definitely
better here white is playing without
risk just because you've gotten rid of
the bishop as you're implying doesn't
mean that white doesn't have the other
advantages of the position so some of
the opening choices have been puzzling
and maybe Notre back has the kind of
good memory effect because he did win
technically the last game in this line
it was due to Wesley's internet but
still maybe he kind of wants to rub it
in a little bit
H5 wow I look back
and we have a big attack on the way
so does white want to go H3 to meet H4
with G4 as is typical
is
I don't know if you want to over commit
with white and play H4 seems kind of
crazy
um agree
G4 Square being a juicy spot for the
night no Wesley goes 92.
going around to F4
all right
so how is black and that address the
problem of Knight F4 because once the D5
Pawn collapses your whole position is
liable to collapse along with it
oh thankfully I don't have to answer
this question and this question is
better reserved for another who
continuously plays into this position
and
seemingly thinks he's okay
whoa
stopping Knight F4
maybe that's what you had to do
but now I have three yeah
we're seeing the Knight back
and Bishop D4 continuing to make
progress in the center
oh that pawn was hanging
apparently it was not a good move
terrible move
just because black has way too many
threats suddenly oh my God Queen C2 D4
oh and B6
oh B6 is a huge threat it's a double
attack that was such a lackadaisical
lackadaisical move you know
it came out of nowhere it just felt
wrong
yeah he was like aha I'm winning your
Pokemon 86 wins the game he just dropped
a piece like on on the spot right there
he has to play Bishop takes B6 and try
to pretend that you have two pawns for
the piece but
his King is now in shambles as well
Nike's gonna come back to C4
that was so crazy he just hung a piece
for no reason
a lot of strange things going on in the
three minute segment Bobby this mattress
taking a strange turn
yeah
okay I'd have five
blundering Knight takes B2
or no Knight takes me to Rook takes C8
yeah rookie in and then
you kind of survived the worst of it
I think there must be a winning move
your motorbike just takes and takes on
B2
he says give me that pawn you've got one
check on H6 and it's totally futile
because of King G7
huh and there it is at age six Knight F5
and you'll just move
just duck back to G8 or even to f8
yeah I was thinking to f8 but they're
probably both completely fine White's
Queen is hanging
it's not being taken uh because black is
in check and that would be illegal
I feel like at least 10 people in the
chat were wondering why the queen was
not being captured
yes
um
what a weird segment
three plus one is so weird
I'm trying to put my finger on like what
exactly has gone wrong for Wesley that
internet game was a big reason like that
really set the tone
but he's also had a couple of games
where he just hasn't managed to create
anything out of promising positions such
as this game
I know I'm very curious to see if we're
gonna get a patch off I doubt we will
what if noji back just shows up next
game and plays D4
that's kind of what I want to see I want
a little change of scenery
H4 wow
Wesley's still trying but rookie eight
yeah just trade the Rooks I mean it is
let's put it this way it's not fun to be
down a piece uh and I'm sure every
single person in the chat uh has been
down a piece probably today
uh but I gotta I gotta wake him up
they're all probably just still arguing
about Johnny Depp I like looked over at
the chat recently I don't know 10
minutes ago they were talking about
Johnny Depp doing some chess commentary
here talking about Johnny Depp uh I
heard that through the grapevine
ha ha ha ha
Queen H2 check and Wesley's not laughing
yeah no he's not laughing Queen H2 what
is it what is he what's he waiting for
what does he not see it H2 wins the
queen or leads to mate choose your
poison okay what was that that was so
strange I think he was like is this too
good to be true
Wesley just seems deflated after that
loss this game was uncharacteristic
where is nojibout going
I think they're going on their halftime
break oh okay yeah they both got up so
quickly I didn't even realize that there
was a that there was a halftime break it
was like
I can't believe we've already had 35
minutes of of three plus one action and
Notre back has tied the match Bobby yes
he's gotten lucky in that one game but
this was perhaps the smoothest game of
the match so far
that was incredibly smooth but it helped
a lot when your top 10 rated opponent
just gives you a bishop that was like
Fisher spassky-esque just took the pawn
in the corner Knight C4 trapped the
bishop and it's a tied match for the
first time since well two and a half two
and a half
yeah that's a great comparison to spaski
Fisher it feels like this match is up
for grabs who can build up momentum and
sustain it over the course of several
games will Wesley's internet remain
stable well there's only one way to find
out we will give the players a breather
and we will take one ourselves the match
is all tied we're having another barn
burner and another match that is very
likely to go down to the wire ladies and
gentlemen so stay tuned we'll be back
with more speed Chess Championship
action from Wesley against outerbeck on
the other side of this short break
[Music]
International Master Danny wrench Chief
chess officer back again with more chess
terms here for you today we're going to
talk about the past Pawn the past Pawn
must be pushed you hear it said often
and that's because just about every end
game you see that isn't a blowout often
comes down to maybe someone's up one
Pawn or maybe even just the first person
to create a past Pawn is the person who
goes on to win that game we're going to
talk about what the past Pawn is and to
find it for you in today's video let's
do it what is a past Pawn a past Pawn is
a pawn that has no enemy pawns stopping
it from moving forward that means pawns
either on the file in which it resides
or on the adjacent files that would
therefore capture the pawn should it
advance so if a pawn has none of those
things stopping its way then it's time
to push them baby as our boy Yasser
would say it as you hear mentioned on
many broadcasts that you would watch on
chess TV and on that note as we look at
our game examples we like to do this is
taken from Thomas chefsky versus rajaba
here white plays the move B5 X Clan
which highlights again it's not how many
pawns you have but who's going to be
threatening to get a queen first after
black takes it white pushes forward with
gusto and because the Rook can't
blockade the pawn due to the light
Square Bishop this game is already over
black is going to have to sacrifice the
bishop for the pawn on B6 and white
would simply be up a minor piece note
that after the first move B5 should a
takes B5 have been played white would
have pushed this pawn and then trap The
Rook on A7 showing the power of the pass
Pawn as with it protecting the bishop
this Rook is completely out of the game
and white would easily go on to win
picking up pawns and just flexing the
rook's muscles over the bishop for the
rest of the game so here we see a pass
Pawn being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
terms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you've
learned something about what a past Pawn
is and we'll see you around on chess.com
[Music]
foreign
thank you
a full screen view of none other than
notorbeck abdusitarov who is locked in a
tied SCC match against Wesley so he has
turned this match around in the
three-minute segment he has benefited
from some shoddy internet but all
credits in Notre back this is going to
be a Barnum burner we have 30 minutes
left of three plus one
maybe obviously when we talk about Notre
back his reputation precedes him he
basically doesn't need an introduction
if you haven't heard of his name that
means you haven't been playing chess for
more than a year
correct and since he doesn't need an
introduction I will not be addressing
anything on this player card uh
just kidding he is the youngest world
champion in any format he became the
world rapid champion and he has an
opportunity actually to kind of defend
that although it's not a match it's an
open format that will be at the end of
December this year he will most
definitely be participating
um he's only ever played in this beaches
Championship once and it actually was a
loss to Wesley so but today's prediction
going into the match was 88 Wesley 12
noji back and the score line a friendly
reminder was nine it was uh 18.5 9.5
that score line looks kind of absurd now
because it's 6.56.5 all right so that
means that Wesley is going to win the
remainder of this match 12-3
uh yeah I don't know I don't think so I
don't think so don't think that's
happening I think don't your back is
flipping everything completely around
well as the underdog you gotta follow
the famous sports advice where you
basically try to shorten the game as
much as possible Right you tell
notabrank hey you can have a tide match
going to the bullet he takes it he
absolutely takes it because the shorter
the match the closer you can make it the
more likelihood there is that something
crazy happens in any individual game
literally any results as possible so
Notre break he's got to be feeling good
right now and Wesley's play just
something seems a little off about it uh
in these last couple of games
blunder here bad internet there he needs
to bring it together
seems like
um the internet thing really
knocked him off base I mean sort of like
that was
was uh was brutal he's got
he's got to recover
and I mean it wouldn't hurt as much if
if he wasn't winning if he didn't play a
perfect game there's nothing like
getting robbed of of a game like that
no it's a horrible feeling and he might
he might not display a lot of outward
emotion
but inside he he ain't happy all right
he ain't happy and uh
we have uh I believe we have liftoff
we do and another Berlin what a surprise
there
we're back to where we started these
guys had like a little rebellious period
there
you know like uh
yeah I don't know it's it seemed like
after the five plus one segment they
were just like good kids got good grades
you know did everything right went to
college and just partied way too hard in
their freshman year got like a 2.8 GPA
now they're back all right they they
pack sophomore junior year they're Back
to Where it All Began that segment was
so weird you know you can also got that
Vibe weird openings lagging I almost
felt like it was a different match
entirely and now they're kind of back to
home base so let's see whether Wesley
can have a stabilizing game I don't
think he even Minds The draw he just
needs something solid uh to to Center
himself again okay so we're getting a
lot of back and forth here that night
moves to G5 and now it's right back on
F3 so what we're just gonna get a
repetition here no obviously God no
Wesley's going for it he's like hey
you're gonna waste a bunch of Tempe I'm
better
he's going for that Bishop Knight back
to E3 what 93 Bishop E6 D4 something
like that
G4 yes G4 rebellious phase is over
oh that's what we all started with that
first game
that was such a bad game like from Dojo
break standpoint and Wesley just played
a brilliant game it was crazy it was too
nil and it was not close
and now it's six and a half six and a
half and I think momentum is on no
direct side I'd be very curious to see
what are the live odds do we have those
notes effect better be in the 30 or the
40 because he was 12 and I think his
highest was 18 that I saw but I don't
know if our live odds are tracking but I
he's got to be at least a 30 or 40 at
this point
oh absolutely absolutely given the
momentum and uh given the trend of the
match again it's all about the trend as
we take a look at the Nifty smarter
chess graphic there the current live
prediction is 32 which given what he
started with is a pretty hefty number
yeah that's nearly 3x
of course smarter chess doesn't have a
variable for Wesley playing on one bar
internet and likely very tilted right
like that's not a statistical Factor
um so I would probably give that about
35 40 but when you play Wesley Daniels
I'm sure you know it all flips in one
game he plays one really good game like
he buckles down and just beats you and
you lose 20 of those percentage points
oh totally he's and and he's just so
hard to get out of his out of his
comfort zone he has this way of just
steering games back into areas that he
feels comfortable and he's doing that
here with a nice little Berlin going for
a structure that he knows very well
and a big question here is which way is
black in a castle knowing Wesley I don't
think he's going Queen side but you
never know
you just never know maybe he won't even
Castle just right
but again F4
yeah wise position looks super super
easy to play
but Bishop B4 is a great move
eliminating
one of White's main attackers and taking
the sting out of the move F4 which he
plays anyway yeah I was gonna say what
exactly are you taking this thing out of
I just didn't I I didn't no because
Bishop C3 bc3 I thought and okay you
prevent Knight D4 but I I
maybe I'm just too optimistic again it's
much easier to move other people's
pieces do you take the Knight here is
that insane
you can take the Knight you can
technically take the bishop although I
don't think he's going to do that
what if you've taken just go back to
Knight F3
looks good to me maybe well again E5
just like in the first game you have to
be very careful of the Bishops sinking
its teeth into D5
well you can just keep these pawns on e4
and F4 to restrict Black's Bishops good
call
or this long Castle too much oh I love
it wow
I'm starting to like Wesley's position
here though Levy because G5 H5 could
come really really quickly
yeah I feel like I was a little bit too
optimistic about blacks like about
White's position versus Black's position
I think noja Beck and I are making the
same mistake wow G5 for wait doesn't
why does the evil bar hate that move
maybe you just take and you no longer
have any Hooks and you can just play
like
what oh 95. and that's a positional move
that's not a tactic it forces the bishop
back to yeah you're just trying to make
territorial gains in the center most
importantly you have to prevent black
from opening up the H file I'm still
concerned for a note of exposition
whoa yeah me too
and look at the clock
okay he doubles on the f file so Knight
F7 is now a positional threat
yeah
White's position is just amazing here
Bishop G6 Wesley does manage to pry the
H file open
yeah he took so fast and now that Bishop
on on B4 is going to go back to D6 at
some point I mean by the way like all
rook and Poland games here
white is so happy black structure is
did he hang a pawn
did he hang upon Queen takes she three
what's his idea Queen she2 no he's just
going for the queen trade well he did he
sack the pawn with
huh I just thinks that the end game is
just gonna be like again he's so
confident in Black structure just being
so bad that
I mean given Wesley's given the clock
situation I think this is a practical
decision but Wesley's basically saying
hey even with the Queen's off the board
I'm still gonna attack you down the H
file Knight G4 though Rook H4
you've got that past E Pawn yeah that
could be a monster in this position I
was gonna say 94 maybe King G3 but okay
there's at least a draw there Rook H3
Rook H4 why we just plays Rook H1 cheese
he wants H3 and Knight G4 and setting up
the Fortress
so ridiculous so does Wesley auru G7 or
E5
rookie eight Maybe
well timed
who's better and why is there's like
some C5 and just bring the king
exactly black might be better here it
doesn't look that way
but you called it C5 King C6 King D5 and
if you win the E7 Pawn
or the five Pawn that is
there's gonna be trouble
okay he's going all in but yo he gave
away a pawn to do this
yeah and I don't get why Wesley didn't
go C5 I thought that was more efficient
but this is good too
King coming to E7 Notre back might lose
this
I think he will
D7 he's trying to defend Everything But
Here Comes G4
oh that's brutal G4 is a brutal move
doesn't hurry with it Knight f8
oh Knight takes G6
oh that's yeah wow oh my God yeah Knight
takes G6
that's crazy is almost trapped night
rookie
F4 wow what a move oh hey he's
gonna win the bishop back that's an
insane idea Rook F4 now
I think why it's fine
yeah
it's still a double-edged position after
Rook H2 very double edged anybody's game
oh my gosh might be better after C4 oh
my God C4 D4
it's crazy people take C6 yeah but he's
just goes like F6
wait taken Rook B5 Rook B5 oh my God
look at five Rook B5 yeah you skip the
move yeah who needs Rook B5 now you
can't take with the Rook he's Gotta Move
oh my gosh A4 G6 let's go off to the
races Rook A6
gonna stop the pawn from behind and he's
gonna have three winning chances here
with no risk
Rook takes A4 just play it
amazing well he's got one second D4 D4
make him make a move make a move
oh my God he's literally going down to
like point two seconds
oh
okay fill it or position
now if I was playing the match I would
milk this down I would maybe melt down
another minute but I don't think he's
gonna do that
yeah he's not yeah he looks like he's
just making oh no he is
wow he is
Rook B5
hoping for a pretty move you know maybe
sometimes everything happens yes okay
there it is all right good save by
Wesley there at the end
very nice that was a fun game oh we're
back we're back to playing fun chess
line that they keep repeating
yeah
um
this just became the thing now those
Rebecca is just playing this and
Wesley's just playing what he's playing
and
uh rookie 8 is the well-timed idea here
so now no no H3 business well are we
sure about that he's like I know you
know what I'm playing H3 earlier than
you are playing Queen D7 you know
there's no uh there's no discover attack
I guess that works or maybe there is
like Bishop C5
just allowing the attackers yeah
wait 23 Queen B6 is that what he wants
I think that's what he wants or maybe
even Knight E4
very very sharp one super sharp game
right now oh Queen B6 yeah Rook C8 I
think Knight E4 actually might be his
idea
and it is
Bishop E4 you play Bishop takes D4
and then Rook takes E4 counter attacks
the queen
okay rookie 4 DTD oh you gotta flip good
Bishop D4
right oh because the bishop is hanging
right geez
yes before yes
I mean listen in my defense Wesley
hunger piece I'm allowed to hang a piece
um Queen T3 by the way is a move that
notabeck might have overlooked because
now you're gonna be able to take the
other Bishop Oh What A Move yeah Queen
D3 is very nice very very nice and you
can tell Notre bakmas that now he's down
a pawn
King G2 Maybe yeah just looking for F3
wins the game
this just looks
well
just I know her back just has to deviate
no yeah no job has to stop playing this
with black
I get that inertia kind of carries me
forward and every time you're like okay
I'm gonna make a small Improvement and
this is the time that I'm gonna equalize
but he never does nope and now it's a
disaster
now this is a very very bad game
you can still try to salvage things I
think after G6 he's still alive
and so he is he's Pawn down Bishop D2
Rook D1 right
and yeah okay he won
okay one well D1
the worst thing is if you had chosen
which Pawn you want to lose at the very
least lose the D5 Pawn now he's down a
pawn and he runs the risk of losing that
pawn in the end
that D4 is just very well protected
doubling up on the H file is coming for
white
in testing the other open file
and trading a pair of Rooks
you can just play it slowly B3 A4 Wesley
loves these type of positions I mean who
doesn't
the thing about Wesley though
C4 the thing about Wesley's what
it's gonna say the thing about Wesley is
he he may not even necessarily just go
all out try to Checkmate he'll just
slowly improve like we've seen him do
this so many times
even in this match but now noisier back
knows that he has a strategy in his back
pocket which is survive as long as
possible
until Wesley Flags because of that
internet it's like somehow it's like a
legitimate strategy
12 minutes to go this three-minute
section has flown by and we've got a
couple of absolutely pivotal games
although judging from yesterday's match
Levy it almost doesn't matter what the
score is going into the bullet because
clearly any of these players are capable
of making a comeback
so I guess I'll hold my tongue whoa
now that's an interesting idea he's
banking on this massive passer on D4
yeah but something tells me this
shouldn't work yeah Queen D2 and maybe
C5 or B4 oh c5's pivotal
yeah if the bishop was already on C5 and
upon was on B6 this would be
yeah we'll actually have been
even better maybe in some positions
but yeah it's still not over
it's just that the d-pawn is so hard to
push forward maybe B6
Renae check King G7 and then quickly try
to push D3
Queen A8 Queen D5
I think it should be winning
we'll have time for
but maybe one more depending on how long
this goes but
yeah I would guess two more
but you're right if this if this takes
another couple minutes then
the next game might be the last
and breathe a that's a paper tiger
a what and a paper tiger
paper tiger I use that expression at
least once per commentary
paper tiger I like that might make my
next screen name paper tiger paper tiger
yeah
A5 is not a paper tiger no
before it's brutal
now Asics Bishop G1 is a May threat but
white always has this move G5
to create looks for the king and it's on
yeah almost but not quite
still keep going
yeah still going yeah yeah
okay where's The Knockout is it Queen B8
and A7 Queen e one
Oh I thought Queen E1 was just winning
but that also works
next screening one there was Rook H2 Amy
yeah but King G4 what
I guess the bishop can move
all right Queen D4
F4 or that
oh from Notre back again I would try to
milk the clock down a little bit but I
think he's just gonna resign
or not
or not keeps it going King three or King
G3 no now he's gonna resign yeah yeah
there we go so
probably the next game is the last game
of the Blitz and it's a probably a must
not lose game like a one point matches
doable two-point matches doable we've
even seen a three-game match just doable
going into the bullet but
I don't think I don't think nausea break
is going to show up and win four
straight games to start the bullet
segment I don't think either of them are
going to but
it honestly feels like Wesley's back to
his old tricks and back to his old ways
he has fully stabilized after that brief
interlude at the start of the three
minute portion
but can motorbeck make something of this
structure
the rebellious Breakaway I know um
yes
I mean another bank needs to be careful
he's playing way too outlandish of an
opening I mean a Berlin come on man
gotta respect the game
I feel like we've had this structure on
the board like 20 times no literally
every single game ugh it's like uh it's
like a bad movie Loop that you just
can't snap out of
here are the chances down to 12 again
like how much how much did noisy back
lose for losing that game
it's got to be higher than that I would
probably guess about 15 to 20 but we'll
get smarter chess to update his
predictions there we go it's still at 28
percent
it's still at 28 which is pretty
generous
it's not bad
and speaking of generous F5 I think is
Wesley's
idea here on tap
and then King's Indian style derived the
pawn down F4 and start attacking
what do you think about that I I
actually I really like how it looks well
like white has to actively figure out a
way to do to prepare against that
92 man I don't know how they don't get
lost in like all of these different move
orders and ideas I mean I know that
might sound naive
but
I there are just so many overlapping
different plans all right castles he
doesn't go F5 after all
yeah he's kind of I think he overcooked
it though I I saw no reason to delay F5
now you're giving white a chance to
complete his development guess what E5
is now hanging and before you know it
white might be the one to go F4 but not
immediately because of B5
dislodging one of the knights from the
other one
yeah that's very funny well
I'm getting a Deja Vu of one of those
first games that we saw where the pawn
and A5 and A4 were both very weak after
black played B5
I remember those good old days
yeah when no direct played G4 that was
cool
yeah all his troubles felt so far away
Bishop B4
the way this is trending we will get one
more Blitz game
oh I think so yeah yeah six minutes to
go and the position is opening up
good night back to B2 D2 sorry and we
have please this is positioned
complicated
yeah it might still go on G3 F4 that's
gotta be the idea right no okay Bishop
C3 I don't understand a lot of you know
a lot of poking and prodding going on
here
just kind of provoking weaknesses
dropping things back throw nope no draw
I thought maybe repetition but okay
but this doesn't seem too impressive for
white even after F4
this is crazy just gave him the whole a
file
they found black could also bring the
pawn up to C5 if he wants to cover some
of these dark squares and maybe use them
as infiltration squares
this seems wild wild from those ear
breaks to play like this but
yeah I think repeating was definitely
more wise
oh God Knight F3 Bishop takes B3
yeah hello yeah I was gonna say just
play H3 but like you're gonna run out of
Moves Like H3 soon
yeah you're gonna run out of moves a lot
faster than black black has a bunch of
these helpful moves D4 is a trick here
he's trying to go D4
yes
can he can he still play D4
you could you absolutely could play D4 I
think that's a great call and then white
will be threatening E5 and before you
know it Black's King could get caught in
the Whirlwind
if you allow black to play C5 I'm not
sure your position's any good at all so
you might have to play D4 agree
completely maybe Knight B1 I thought
briefly
but then after Queen E5 you're not gonna
get D4 in there it is on the board good
call we we await for the blessing of the
machine I feel like that's just how we
play chess now we're like I have an idea
ah
ah and then it kind of like
blessed it Wesley has to tread very
carefully and I like Rook A1 forcing the
trade of Brooks was there Knight B1
there
could you have just played Knight
through one okay one ip1 I guess Queen
B2
led to an unclear position
wow this is sharp man past Pawn now on
D5
speaking of unclear
he didn't want to trade Queens but I
don't know I felt like maybe Queen G3
was okay maybe G3 was better to try to
play Queen F4 somehow but
okay yeah the ultimate goal is to
dislodge the queen from E5 but then the
Queen's gonna be replaced with a knight
that's
not better Notre back might be losing
control of the game here a little bit
yeah agreed
I don't know oh man's the night there's
there's no threat at all but it's still
oh boy
does that move do anything can black
just go C4
or I mean yeah I can go C4 and he plays
it but maybe Notre big takes on E5
oh Bishop takes D5
oh no what's he done he's just so he's
just totally bungled it
he has bungled it and maybe repeating
moves when he had the chance would have
been wiser oh no
we're gonna get another game Wesley
should be winning this
okay threatening to sneak
Queen A7
back to F7
yep
yep now this is completely winning
just Queen C3 Maybe
oh that is a sick move yeah and then
take it might be one B4 you could also
just take it B3 but
um
oh you take take C3 and then Bishop
takes B3
wait why didn't he take the pawn on C2
what was I missing I don't think you
were missing anything I think he just
literally forgot I
yeah he's still winning 140 left on the
match clock in this segment we will have
30 minutes of bullet to follow so the
match is not over what wait what is
happening in this game what okay why is
any of this game the pawn again might
not be winning for white no it is it is
King F6 and H6 for black not for white I
would hope for black for black
wait a second white winning here would
be
this no but you have E43 right you've
you've I thought you would do 43. well
E4 E3
I I think basically what you should try
to do here is play B4 at the right
moment such as now
oh my God wait what did he just allow a
draw oh
oh
my God
holy lands
he was King D3 Kings is just a draw
this is insane my lands
no make them make a move
oh Notre back might be winning he's
no way and this will be the last game of
the segment I think ah this right yes
unless we just have a repetition oh good
God
good grief now who's better White's got
the passer but Black's gonna win G4 this
is anybody's game
uh uh now knows
oh he totally should have went for the
draw yeah it knows your bike's sitting
there like what am I doing
all right well this one wait F1 oh Queen
F1 Queen F1 is winning oh my gosh and
now we've got another simultaneous
promotion
yeah this is what's up Buckle in folks
I mean not your back has a very small
chance of saving this game but his King
is just in the open it's like impossible
to check
you're exactly right it makes it almost
impossible to defend in the long run
King G3 and queen G4 choke
yep
Queen G4 that's it
oh no they're Becky
repeat moves man
yeah that was crazy that was so crazy I
mean he he yeah he's in disbelief we're
in disbelief and
he I mean there was repetition on the
board and he just got a bit greedy I
don't know that was the best way to
describe it and
that's uh
heartbreaking that would have been a
crazy save I mean he was so lost but he
just got over ambitious and Wesley so
kept his composure in that Queen end
game you found a couple of accurate
moves and he delivers a dagger to go up
by two points so at a two point lead it
is nothing we are set up for an epic
bullet Showdown we'll have 30 minutes to
decide who wins and advances to the
round of eight so don't go anywhere
before we go on a short break we wanted
to remind you to get ready for the
December 2022
stateofchess.com coming to you live on
December 21st we have some huge news for
the chess community and the event will
be followed by a Community Q a plus some
very special guests will be joining the
show to talk about the exciting
announcement and what it means for the
future of Chess and the chess Community
do not miss this show December 21st 10
a.m PST 1pm EST right here on twitch.tv
chess well don't miss the conclusion of
this first of our SEC double header
we'll be back with the decisive bullet
segment between Wesley so and Notre
backup new sotorov on the other side of
this spring
foreign
[Music]
first learned about ill Cafe through my
buddy Aaron he was like Hey me and a
group of fellas meet at this Cafe
downtown on Sundays and we play chess
there it'd be really cool if you could
stop by and hang out with us and you
know just feel the vibe and so I showed
up
and it was a nice bike I was like yo ill
Cafe is pretty ill
Ness
[Music]
foreign
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh my goodness the wheels the wheels
have come out that could be the match
for some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabby
source
the electricity
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
I apologize for that welcome back to the
speed Chess Championship were you muted
that whole time I was muted the whole
time yeah the whole time
I could hear you I could hear you can
hear me that's the important part right
well it's been a ridiculously
topsy-turvy match in the first of our
double header between Wesley and Notre
Beck Wesley Leeds by two points after
that ridiculous final game of the three
minute segment folks it's been a
pleasure bringing you this match
alongside International Master Levy
Rosman Levy what haven't we seen and
what aren't we going to see in these
next 30 minutes I don't know I mean
we're off to a good start I had no idea
you were even muted I was just sitting
here listening to your fantastic show
open and then I realized you apologized
it's so smooth that was very good chat
missed the show opening of a lifetime
yeah listen
um smarter just had this match at 12-6
at this point uh it's nine seven I mean
you can't really ask for much more than
that if you're a noiser back I mean he
was close to tying the match and um even
taking the lead in this match just a
handful of times but
um
I mean we are we've got a bullet segment
here on the way
and I think I don't know I think we're
gonna see some spectacular stuff
and thus far in situations where one
side has been down two or three points
we saw this in the aronian and draken
match we saw this yesterday
we have had some crazy bullet comebacks
and they've often started at the very
beginning for example anishikiri won I
think the first four bullet games
levonne aronia did something similar so
Wesley so just has to put those matches
away from his mind and I think he's got
to try to strike early seat belts fasten
ladies and gentlemen here we go
yep here we go we have our first
completely new opening of the entire
match
and uh
well hey I mean
this is this is not easy this is not
easy Wesley looking backwards again
getting bothered by something
with the room again yeah what what does
Wesley have back there like is he
hitting his modem a few times like yeah
like hello wake up
yeah wow okay well now I like this end
game for Wesley I think this is the kind
of position he has to strive for in a
bullet game
uh yes I think so too also they only
have 30 minutes and uh a game like this
can take a solid four of them off the
clock if you play it right totally we've
even seen five minute bullet games
and with you know a deficit of more than
one point you always have to keep an eye
on the clock
and strip G5 Bishop G5 yeah Bishop G5
just looked like it was winning or close
um because there was Bishop B5 check
all right Rook somewhere I mean white
has everything Bishop pair more activity
Queen side majority
what does a lot of time
I mean Wesley can slow down take his
time Notre Beck is going to try to push
this Pawn down to E4 and generate King
side activity and he does
E4 is a very nice move very very nice
Wesley has a blind
Dania he has a like a weird blind spot
for just allowing these massive Pawn
chains he's done it twice in this match
yeah
it's strange and he's borderline lost
now that Rook Honey 2 is tied down look
at that Beast of a knight on F5 Rook H6
is an idea yeah I'm not cheering for
Wesley's downfall I'm simply cheering
for more chess and I don't want to see
anybody have a three-game uh deficit
which we haven't had in this match by
the way it's actually a very close match
yeah every time it seems like Wesley is
about to deliver the death blow
neuterbeck has come back and put
together a win he has to convert this
into a full point
can he do it
this looks fantastic for black G3 is a
great practical move though great
practical move
yeah but black doesn't have to go
anywhere that's the problem
you can just
I mean the pawn end game is always lost
right like because of the Pawn on E3
drawing chances here wow they just both
go directly into it I mean how is this
not hopeless it's got to be hopeless it
is a Black's gonna go well it's actually
not that simple black plays A4 and then
Levy at the end black can actually give
away the e-pawn for the C pawn and then
shoulder white king out of the gate he's
gonna win the first game here we go with
this again wow
wow I mean that was just so strange
Wesley is like glitching all over the
place and again fixing something behind
him I know
and the bullet that's gonna cost you
that is gonna cost you three minutes off
the clock and it's a one game match once
again I mean it listen this match has
been Wesley trying to drop knows your
big deeper into the well and when and
and you know knows you're back crawling
out of it he has never LED in this match
ever but
it's 9-8 I mean it's not an 18 and a
half to nine and a half or whatever it
was predicted totally and and if you
keep crawling out of it you know Wesley
gets more and more frustrated
and again the match if you're Notre back
you want the match to come down to the
final game and I like his position here
again H4 love it H4 I would have played
without even thinking
okay Bishop B6 trade Queen B3 attacking
both bonds at once
yes uh
oh this is an amazing position for white
I mean am I you take C5
it D yeah I thought D just looked great
just take the slightly better position
and I don't I wouldn't have allowed the
Knight to go to F4 but
huh so White's gonna go Rook a to D1 try
to organize some pressure down the
center
here it is
oh I don't know about e takes D4 that's
a very committal move giving up a lot of
the center
Rook C1
men am I just like imagining things this
position looks just incredible for I
wouldn't have gone D5 though but it's
fine
yeah D5 may be a little bit overly
committal
just The Rook okay H3 prevents G4 which
makes sense
but with the G file open Wesley now has
long-term prospects on the king side he
just has to solve the problem of his C
punch
oh and his beep on and his e-pawn
the whole Center the whole Center by the
way
before yeah yeah Rook D4 is going to get
some key exchanges here but you got to
take with the c pawn and then you're
down two on one on the queen side I
don't know what whoa Rook takes D4 Rook
C1 and Rook C6 looked mighty good there
kind of keeps the status quo
just take on D4 like am I missing
something I mean he blundered his Queen
oh my gosh he is in disbelief I'm in
disbelief I mean just hung beef I mean
just Rook D4 there Auto move right like
Total Auto move and he he was the one
who walked his Queen to A5 he did that
on his own volition and then he nailed
his own coffin with B4
that was so wild I mean he just over
thought it he just over complicated the
situation that's a present games like
that change matches like it's so hard to
bounce back a big Miss because he was
better out of the opening he was doing
everything right he won that game it
would have been a tight match and now
the lead is back to that pesky two
points that Notre back has had such a
hard time coming back from entirely
I know we've had a
it's it's hard to offset your opponent
having bad internet when you hang a
queen that's that's tough
that's tough that's always going to be
tough
and I've been impressed with notorbeck's
opening play I think he's got a good
position again if he goes Knight F6 here
maybe bishop G5 in response
is Wesley's idea
okay okay yeah
oh oh oh that is a dagger
that's a tough move yeah Rook C1 could
be could be okay it could be all right
maybe it's not the end of the world
computer seems to hate it but
yeah but there's a lot going on here
Queen C2 is a great move
oh that is a great move defend the
bishop increase the pressure on C6
Black's losing that pawn
and perhaps even the game
and perhaps even the match I mean this
is this would be the first three-game
lead yeah it's it's so hard to bounce
back after you blunder B4 Rook A8
yup
you know this has to be totally winning
for white and at this point Wesley's
starting to think about milking as much
clock as possible out of these games
maybe Wesley's lactose intolerant maybe
he's not thinking about milk for some
reason I knew you were gonna let that
pass that opportunity pass by I should I
just I you know these milk and stuff too
much too much milking going on
uh yeah I mean that's a passer and um he
ain't stopping it no what makes it so
depressing is the total lack of counter
play like white can play this for an
eternity okay another book has to create
the password and he does
yep B5 is going for it he's done well
yeah uh wait oh how does Wesley avoid
the repetition uh I don't think it takes
B5 yeah yeah baby but he doesn't he
loves the draw
oh Lance am I am I
am I crazy for thinking that's not a
good decision like that I don't think it
is
but Wesley is so responsible I feel like
there are very few top players who would
have made a draw there they would have
just tried to win it like because they
know that they're winning West is like I
might be winning but two game lead 20
minutes good luck
it's a reasonable decision this is a
pivotal game notorbeck has the white
pieces I think in bullet
the choice for Wesley to go for this
Petrov line is pretty questionable this
is such an easy position to play for
white but Wesley just knows all of the
ideas here and once he goes rookie eight
like where is White's advantage
uh
uh I don't know where White's advantages
it's a great question they're back to
this line New Jersey
okay Queen F5 Maybe
it goes Knight F5 still a little pull
for white here yeah I really like this
position
for white as always
I would have considered Knight H6 check
but okay
the king is the the king is the one
playing the defense yeah wait what
Knight H4 Knight f8 I mean
it almost looks like white night age
gorgeous I think Knight H4 won the game
there
because Knight f8 Bishop takes right but
motorbike is rushing he's got over 50
seconds and he's not spending any time
in critical moments I think he's rushing
past a lot of chances that Wesley has
given him this game
he's trying to play Fast more than
trying to play Super accurately
Knight back to C2
just be careful about some Knight F4 and
Knight E5 there's a lot of forks here
Knight F Fork
okay Queen goes back to E2 yeah I mean
again I'm I'm really enjoying White's
position here
yeah Notre pick is still pressing now DC
and Knight takes D4 has to be calculated
here I'm gonna let Wesley do that
night D3 Knight E5 I mean yeah you
whoa this cannot be right uh
4 Knight no but then Queen A2 and then
Queen D5 Queen C4 you have
oh my gosh wow wow oh wow oh my God
Queen C4 here oh that's what I said see
that oh my God no now I get it I was
like why did that one there's a queen
the knights on after he's pinned
nope
yeah put that in your pipe
sorry I'll get a cute I'll get accused
of reading the engine even though I
can't even see it I can only see an evil
no I know you can't see the engine I
literally have it on uh Bishop B4 and
that's that wow that was sick let's go
now let's go I didn't even see Queen A2
much less Queen takes C4 listen listen
my Dynamic skills 2700 everything else
400 it balances you know what I'm saying
like everything else everything else I'm
just getting up there in the triple
digits grinding you know looking at my
Donya speedrun Sensei speedrun series
got to build up those positional skills
that was a little dose of nasty from
Notre back and guess what this is not
considered a good line for black after
Knight G3
no no I love this line for white I don't
know how if you've played a lot of it
Rook a two Knight G3 E4 you always five
one zero anytime people go with this for
this with black I'm like the happiest
man on Earth Yep
yep yep yep these positions I but you
know sometimes I get like a very good
opponent with black and they just defend
everything like I've never played this
against Wesley you know what I mean yeah
we're an automatic for that matter
but uh H5 very typical in such positions
as an antidote to E4 so that you go H4
and you soften up that pawn now white
can go E4 anyway in many cases
yes visually this looks like stunning
for Bishop B2 and yeah I mean I I just
feel as though like the position never
works for black
just yeah somehow there's just too many
like tactical shots Rook takes F6 is
actually quite common
okay not anymore
wait a second it's plus five oh I guess
he does have Rook F6 and Rook C2
oh Lobby Rook C2 ended the game on the
spot
yeah uh whoa whoa whoa whoa Knight takes
D4
and again Wesley's taking his foot off
the gas pedal Knight F5
wow
and I guess there's Queen G4
But Here Comes
wait oh that's brutal Rook H6 Queen
takes H6 and the g Pawn is pinned oh
what motorbike says I'm just gonna bring
another Rook end to the game that's so
funny
it's amazing how do you defend against
Rook H6
like that
I mean that doesn't defend Rook H6 but
at least you don't lose a queen oh Queen
C7 is tricky what is going on but the
Knight on D4 is caught in the crossfire
you could end up losing a minor piece
here
I don't know what to play defense
Rook
uh G6 Queen D4
somehow the evil bar is still showing
Advantage for black You're Gonna Lose
the bishop on B2
oh this is unbelievable
yes and then Rook H or Rook G3 Rook
takes G3 and Rook G6 check with an
Unstoppable attack
oh I think G3 was winning this still
looks promising for black the king is
out in the open and we're gonna get a
perpetual oh yeah yeah that's so little
no no no play for the win we do it for
Fabi who's in the chat
oh he's running no Rook G7 and E6 Rook
G7 and E6 no wait no no this this might
be Oh Oh It's Made Queen G5
but it's still not over Queen G2 and
yeah but okay wow there was Queen E4
forcing the queen trade
Wesley's gonna win whoa whoa SE or not
sorry sorry not a feed not a fee not if
he just yelling moves
oh my God
this is ridiculous I can't believe the
game's still not over norderbeck's
somehow holding on Queen B7
going back to C6 Queen G3 it's mate
and to E7
oh what a dagger Notre back perhaps his
head he's like what do I have to do did
you see that did you see Wesley just
like pump his hands out that was that
was a huge win for him it was like a
release of pent-up you know emotional
energy right there I mean listen
can't blame him yeah that was a very
stressful game and I mean it looked like
not your back was gonna strike back
again he's been so close to evening this
match so many times unbelievable I was
sure he was gonna win he had Wesley's
King on its last legs
and then yeah was they just King F4 wow
amazing job by Wesley to realize that
that time in particular he should not
repeat moves
yeah you know it was like a Lamar
Jackson moment evading like 17 tacklers
and the King ended up winning the game
for white yeah it just took a walk
all right no it's your back is going all
out here and not in a good way no no no
at all in a good way no is he just gonna
lose a pawn or am I hallucinating this
25 at the end with a fork on A8 aha
so actually notabeck might be making
this work uh oh
if it's bug house let me get a knight to
put on H6 not anymore
so is there a case whoa
so Queen A3 Queen takes E6 but Wesley
just shuts the bishop down with the C5
yeah it's just C5
and Bishop back
I like I like what White's got going on
here a little F5 action never hurt
anybody Queen
okay I was gonna say queen D1 but fine
I'm just worried that when push comes to
shove White's King is gonna end up being
too weak oh 94 there's Rook takes D4 and
queen takes D4 yeah and queen E1 is
covered by the stupid Knight on G2
amazing Defender that night on G2 yes
yes certainly notorbeck has an
initiative after rookie won oh my God
oh my gosh you got like A4 for white
when you want it so just some Queen C4
stuff oh my gosh you can no no rookie
one mate rookie one mate rookie one is
mate he blundered made in one and now
he's gotta dial back and he's down in
exchange rookie one Quincy seven one
zero yeah it's over
oh my gosh no and that was yet another
howler Rook H1 Rook H1
well Bishop B oh no not Bishop B2 Knight
never was hanging E1 was hanging okay
okay oh and this might have been the
dagger it's still only a three-point
match there's plenty of time left on the
match clock well but this is it like not
your back has to win every game now he
has time for three games
and he's got to be perfect you know who
is perfect we had a guest in the chat
recently it was Mr caruana that's a
that's a perfect man right there so I
don't know if he's still here maybe one
about his day but uh
I mean I Gotta Throw I gotta go throw
some compliments back by the way crazy
he's going back for this because
he did not get a good position last time
this has been a tough match man honestly
this match has just been Wesley is just
that much better at the right moments
that's it yeah really it and honestly
Wesley would be the first to admit that
I mean his form was topsy-turvy he had
some incredibly impressive games and by
the way we we know the match isn't over
but broadly speaking
as I mentioned in the Carlson match it's
not about how good you are when you're
in good form it's whether you can beat
really serious players when you're in
mediocre form that's the real
determinant of greatness I think at this
level in this format why is Notre back
repeating this line and this is flat out
terrible for black
uh I yeah he he he's sort of been frozen
a few times I feel like just he just out
of and I listen I've been there I'm not
gonna compare my you know my uh division
three level chess matches in the I am
not a James beaches championship against
this stuff but sometimes you just can't
snap out of it you just because
having prep that's bad you still get 15
20 moves quick right problem is at this
level so does the other guy
and then he gets a great position and he
crushes you so now he's made he's made
lemonade out of lemons I think Notre
back is still surviving here
he just needs a good move in this
position maybe drop back the Knight to
G7 try to trade some Rooks
right F4 yep it admittedly yeah I mean
no jibex positions okay suddenly I think
black might be on the better side of
this
just don't blunder anything
yeah don't go Knight H3
oh Queen C1 doesn't quite work E2 is
protected not quite not quite
so I guess you have to go Knight H5 man
Black's position still looks so loose
he's six queen of seven
the Knight hangs on G3 also
what the heck is going on no no Bishop
H6 and Knight F5
I misses it
oh my gosh but this is also I can't
believe this
uh does he have Bishop no that's insane
King G8
no Queen E8 and uh
Queen F7 back or something
wait I mean was there Queen d8 there or
something
I guess so he just gets his Knight
around to E3 there's no way Notre back
saves this was six seconds Knight E3
still possible no and D5 Falls but then
there's Queen E1 with perpetual
whoa
suddenly Notre pick back in the game
again
Knight D6 hello Queen F4 hangs a queen
don't play that progress
thank you for the ponce's nutter back on
King G6 attacking the bishop
Knight F7 Knight F7 oh God that also
works oh whoa
okay now Notre back really cannot afford
a draw here
no but a draw keeps him in the match a
loss loses immediately
I mean with a four point lead that'll be
an F4 no yeah four looks like
it's black oh
Knight F3 check Knight F3 check was
possible
H4
whoa the night circling around to
everything
my H5 it's over but you can't make
blunders like this and I hoped it would
be Wesley
yeah yeah that's it I mean these are
these are howlers
that's oh my God that doesn't that seals
it
well I hate to be that guy Levy but
remember that all they have to do is get
the game off in time
so there is time for four games correct
you're right I'm actually I'm being a
very bad host as a host I'm supposed to
you know the match could be 21-0 and I
can say well there's a chance that you
know
um
but no I agree with you and we know that
if Wesley even so much as makes a draw
or has one long game then it's over
immediately right
but we've seen all sorts of crazy things
in the SEC
uh
Bishop G6
ice move my motor back
that was a
that was a good fight
it's a good fight no you're back
he had his chances for sure
yeah no he definitely did he had plenty
of chances to tie But ultimately those
games Levy where
he even in those games came very very
close to tying but just didn't have that
extra clutch Factor
although I think he might win this game
pretty quickly
and then we'll start talking again
I don't know I don't know about all that
that's a big claim but yeah really
quickly might be a bold statement here
Rook takes two six Knight takes H4 and
let's just G4 no white is winning
mine is definitely winning
wait why work G4 why not G4
why allow The Rook trade
yeah Notre back has been off today he's
had a lot of these uncharacteristic
mistakes
now his Advantage has evaporated
yeah yeah I think that's all she wrote
well we got six minutes to kill what do
you want to talk about
yeah it's been a weird match I have to
say that it's hard to kind of put a
finger on who had the momentum what was
even going on by the way motorbike might
still win this game King B7 no he is
gonna win this game I think I still
think we should keep talking about the
match six minutes left in the match
clock
uh if he wins this match yes but I mean
come on a game takes minimum three
minutes he might make it get it within
one
but
it's going to come down to Wesley just
sitting there letting his clock run out
and then
motorbike is going to have to win one of
the games in like basically a minute
by the way
this one this one is still almost over
but Wesley can continue milking a ton of
time off this clock oh and this is gonna
take forever yep yeah yeah this is gonna
take at least like 90 more seconds
but you guys shouldn't leave we have a
match right after this by the way so
yeah and it will start very very shortly
um after the conclusion of this one by
the way I think Wesley might save the
game
92 there's no checks oh my God Knight G2
was just holding the game it literally
like there was no black was playing for
a win at that point exactly if the queen
of knights they don't oh my gosh
it's that spot in the match where you
can't buy a game you know what I mean
like there's just nothing you can do
it's like no matter how hard you try and
look at Wesley clinical he's gonna build
up as much time as possible and then
milk another 15 seconds off the clock
why did he run to the edge no no no that
was not
but Wesley could have stayed in the
center he didn't have to run to the edge
of the board I think another 15 seconds
might have actually been the difference
between like a mathematical win in the
match okay now this is the big game can
notrepeck get one quickly
get one quickly why doesn't noji break
play like a modern
I mean he's playing Mainline qgd
I just like you gotta win in a minute
you know what are you gonna play you
know yeah that's gonna blow up the
universe or whatever
oh man yeah it's it's tough it's tough
but this was a this was much closer than
we thought but it's tough yeah nojebec
hasn't had a single game where he he led
the match
um he tied it up multiple times but
unfortunately
pressure of Wesley just
listen he had some very impressive
moments I I'm still impressed by the way
he handled the start of the match
because we thought again 2-0 we thought
Wesley was gonna blow him out of the
water Notre back kind of kept his
composure had that really impressive
positional game with the King march by
the way Knight D3
and Wesley has something really careful
here that is a cool move yeah Notre back
once again kind of in charge in this
game
but it's late I almost I almost said
Knight F5 just hanging Queen C5 that
would have been pretty cool wait a
second
I think Wesley's in trouble after G6
that Rook could get trapped and
Levy if he wins this game in the next
minute he has a fighting chance I'm
serious he has a serious Fighting Chance
uh yeah and he's sitting there look at
that he's like guy he's like what am I
doing he's taking his time okay he's
winning you know yeah you know uh no no
I meant I meant Wesley like he you could
see he's smiling he's like all right I'm
gonna stall it out but I gotta tell you
he
if you make a very good player play
badly on purpose just to like stall the
clock he might actually expedite his own
demise and he is he is Expediting his
own demise he's that's it he it's he
lost his Knight and Wesley is playing
the clock rather than playing the board
he's playing terribly he's only looking
at the match clock and he might still be
able to Bleed It Out take the queen move
no that was a bad move Queen takes d8
oh my okay Notre back just needs to
pre-move his way to Victory and look at
how he clinically he's doing it oh my
God I should Levy this is not over no
this is not over this is insane why
didn't Wesley keep the bishop on what is
Wesley doing
yeah Wesley's not 8382 A1 as much as he
can
but Notre back every second is golden
just made him already
B5 just go B5 no you're back
now why is Wesley moving oh my God why
did he move
D dude this is nuts no there's no way
there's no way no no there's no way no
four games in eight minutes is too much
man stop it
okay so 145 we we need to remind you of
something very important as long as
there is still time on the match clock
after the game ends the next game Begins
the problem is that Wesley's just gonna
build up a minute and stall it out Notre
Beck needs to pre-move his way to
Victory Knight G4 go go go go go Knight
G4 this is so nuts
you just gotta go for mate here I don't
even I don't think we had any time to
change the the aren't isn't it oh wait
oh sorry Notre Beck's white notable
Bishops
oh no Rebecca that is all she wrote oh
oh what a valiant effort though yeah
that was no no that's it
wow wow
whoops
that was swell anti-climactic yes the
excitement was there you know the idea
was good but unfortunately the execution
was uh faulty if he had conserved an
extra minute that's all he really needed
he would have had a serious Fighting
Chance
yeah but this
40 seconds hung two queens in Bullet by
the way yep because he hung that Queen
early with yeah yeah that was when the
match almost he could have tied the
match and that was a close game the
second game of the bullet I think or the
third job yeah no he had he had a much
better position there if he had taken
that Rook on D4
I think we might be singing a different
tune right now
but Wesley just wins matches oh wait
blunters a knight in one move which has
Wesley so
Wesley just just jump out of his chair
and clap his hands he's like what am I
doing
okay that's it it is the match is
officially over
this game will purely be cosmetic
Wesley isn't happy yeah he's gonna win
the match but he's uh it's the last game
syndrome it's like when you exit the
tournament on a loss even in good shape
you're just like so mad
yeah it kind of leaves a bad taste in
your mouth and you know this is not the
precedent that Wesley wants to set
because again if he had a closer match
somebody like MBO might not let him go
might not forgive some of these mistakes
Wesley's just going to resign
and he ends with a whimper but
he did what he had to do Levy he just
that's what great players do
they do what they have to
yeah that was a
strong performance from Wesley not in a
display of dominance but as you said in
a display of being clutch and being
accurate and being precise just at the
right moments when he had to
and he was and he is our winner for
today's match
he is there were a lot of really fun
moments today they went back and forth
a lot of momentum on both sides Notre
back had his chances he came back
several times in the match but
ultimately our final score ladies and
gentlemen in this first match of our
double header is 14 and a half to 12 and
a half Wesley so makes his way to the
round of eight we can take one quick
look at the bracket before I'm gonna
sign it off and hand it over to our
other set of hosts for our second match
between Hikaru and paravian but we
should point out that Wesley so advances
to face some guy named mvl Levy not the
worst player in the world
definitely not he was here earlier
scouting the competition uh Wesley does
move on to face him on the other side of
the bracket we got a
got a world championship rematch what an
insane tournament I mean everybody here
is just so so good
um Fabiano putting up a huge win against
Eric icy so really really impressive
work from everybody making it from the
round of 16 to the round of eight
and um yeah Wesley's gonna have to snap
out of it though I think he is Wesley
can't he can't do what he did today
against mvl it ain't gonna go well it's
not and given uh mbl's performance
against Yan uh Wesley will have to bring
his a game but right now David paravian
is gonna have to bring his A-game ladies
and gentlemen in 15 minutes the second
match of the doubleheader will be
beginning Hikaru Nakamura will finally
make his SCC debut against the qualifier
David per avian a very strong
Grandmaster who is no walkover so on
that note without further Ado folks I
will we will take the short break Levy
always a pleasure covering these matches
with you was early but it was super
super fun so thank you everybody for
joining bright and early Levy and our
entire commentary team at chess.com
thank you for another Flawless broadcast
and on that note we will take a short
break and then James Canty and
Grandmaster Jeffrey Zhang will pick it
right back up with you to call the
Hikaru for Arabian match bye for now and
see you in just a couple
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]